up
so few cool things happen
um this hyper parameter
sweep I don't know what all of these
ones are I don't know why there's so
many that are this
exact
reward um this is kind of
odd but it looks
like even over this huge number of
runs Let me refresh this I think they're
more than this oh that's right even over
this huge number of runs it's kept
getting better and better over time
which is really cool to see from uh from
carbs and it's picked some weird stuff
as well which is
interesting but we'll mostly let that
run in the background and I have one
other thing running in the background as
well and we're going to do some madev
today uh I think going to start off with
some pretty easy stuff we're going to
clean up the project a a little bit
really would like to have this in a
state where um
It's relatively Fe feasible to add stuff
to it code's a
mess I'm going to start with that um
going to change the data structures out
a little bit and then we're going to see
from there um there's a little bit of UI
stuff to add a little bit of data
structure stuff to add we want to add
like cool Downs to abilities and stuff
like that probably going to have to
change up the new nums of stuff um we're
going to have to reformat stuff so that
the environment is easier to
reset
and we might do leveling or something
like that already I don't
know would be really cool if we already
had like something that the agents could
uh could technically learn to play and
then of course we'll have to add uh
major elements we have a dock here
somewhere right yeah yeah so we have
this we don't have this we have
this um we've got the lanes we've got
the towers we've got we don't have the
objective yet we need the Min minions
and maybe
neutrals uh we don't have multiple
Heroes so yeah there's still some things
we need to do
here let's uh let's just start coding on
stuff really really exhausted today did
a 9 and 1 half mile run this morning and
then some
lifts program's kicking my ass but uh
we're still here doing Dev and I think I
can still get some Pro uh some good
progress in on this today because
Project's in a decent spot
so first thing I want to do is just look
at what a mess we have with all of this
code here uh we have this is the SE
environment we have
some attributes agents groups Towers
Vision
speed this is
fine grid and
observations I think until we mess with
data structures these are all mostly
fine
um this here should not be done on a
net this should be part of uh reset I
would say
make do we make the objects on a
net no this can all just go into into
reset
right yeah so let's get rid of these
reset unfortunately this is an
environment that has to be uh resettable
right there's no way
around this environment needing
resets so
okay top bottom lots of
stuff we don't actually need any of
these because the borders are handled by
the game map so we can get rid of this
Tower a little bit obnoxious how I have
to write all this stuff out like
this
um but it's it is kind of hardcoded like
the way that this is
we could potentially do uh like make T3
we could like make some functions for
well but for now let's just get stuff
into the right functions at least
so this move to function here
[Music]
obnoxious oh man there's just so much
stuff here that needs to be messed
with I'm actually looking at this I
think that the best way to clean this up
is going to be able to is just going to
be to change the stru type
right all right time to pay the piper
and do some refactor so I thought about
this a little bit
and I do think
that the easiest way to do this is going
to just be to have one entity type
um it would be nice to have subtypes or
something but really like the easiest
thing to do is just going to be to
change this to entity
oops it's not going to need to have PID
if we design it
correctly yeah it shouldn't need to have
pit if we design it
correctly uh it's going team health max
health YX spawn X spawn Y and needs a
float
damage now we can get this and now we
can
do entity D
type and then this actually kills all of
these
entities
entities hey man subed from your thesis
defense video amazing stuff I assume you
work successful keep on making
expressive stuff yes thank you very much
I uh I graduated a couple months ago I'm
now working on making reinforcement
learning a usable and consistent field
uh doing a lot of high perf engineering
doing environment Dev doing simulation
Dev doing like surrounding
infrastructure with environment
compatibility and Hyper parameters just
generally trying to make this a place
where we can continue making progress
and fixing the last decade's worth of RL
hygiene problems uh so that's what's
going on here is just been streaming
live Dev on a lot of the little things
I've been working
on here's one cool thing since I do have
a couple gifts around they're all on my
Twitter but
um we made this a couple weeks ago this
is snake with 4096 snakes that runs at
14 million steps single core so 14
million snake steps per second single
core and trains it a million steps per
second we also have other fun particle
Sims like this from this past
week
uh yeah there's lots of cool stuff
around
here oh yeah and then this is this is
the project I'm working on right now
we're making little mini
MOBA this is day three of MOA Dev so
brand new
entity player OBS and then this is
entity entities
towers oh hey technium yeah I've seen
your uh I've seen your your stuff on X
welcome to the
stream in which we see whether it is
actually easy to make a mooba and I can
just do it in like a week uh or if it
ends up being hard we will find out
the data structures for this are kind of
hard because like I'm not just thinking
about how I want to design this for the
mooba I'm also thinking about doing this
in a way that's convenient for
reinforcement learning so like maybe if
I were trying to keep the code different
uh or keep the code more for games I
wouldn't do this but given that I'm used
doing this for RL like it's actually
really nice to have everything be the
same entity type um so that's what I'm
currently
doing but yeah I basically just wrote
500 lines of garbage code over the last
two days and I need to pay the piper a
little bit next hour or so on this and
then hopefully we can
start maybe do creep AI today you know
I've been putting creep AI off because
it's kind of hard but uh maybe that
would be a fun thing to tackle today
that would give me something like
something concrete to aim
for that actually sounds kind of fun now
that I think about
player yay creep AI I'm going to try the
creep AI is actually going to be kind of
hard like if you actually the creep Ai
and like Le and DOTA is kind of
sophisticated actually if you think
about it
um or maybe at the very least it's it's
difficult to implement very
entity I figured I'd just start with
this while I uh I mean it was either
like start like start go live and start
streaming this refactor or uh wait for
like an hour for my brain to actually
wake
[Music]
up I've been up since 6 but the run this
morning just kicked my ass a lot of this
stuff is definitely way over my head at
the moment well I'm truly a brave newbie
but yeah your videos make the stuff far
more accessible so yeah thanks um go
look at the uh the snake code if you
want to like dip your toes into like
ultra high perf RL Sim the snake code is
in the dev branch of puffer lib it's
like environments ocean snake that's the
path uh it's 450 lines it's like 220
lines of scon and then 220 line python
wrapper and it's it's all the tech
that's behind all of this
stuff I mean there's a bunch of other
stuff in puffer right I've been doing
hyper pram sweep stuff
oh yeah this is since I see we have a
couple people on this I'll I'll show
this uh let me show this result I got
today so this is a hyper parameter Sweep
with the new carbs integration in uh
puffer this is in bui's carbs hyper
parameter tuning algorithm and this is
182 runs each run of which is at least
uh 500 million
steps so you know this is at least 90
billion steps worth of
data and it's still getting better as of
last night at least or early this
morning and we'll see if it keeps you
know if it discovers anything else I'm
going to let this continue to run um so
yeah things are looking up for
reinforcement learning if we can just
Auto solve environments like
this I have no idea what this policy is
going to look like but this is twice the
reward of the best policy I was able to
train beforehand
okay so the compute observations we
need so this is entity player entity
Target and then Target
uh what did I try to do here I tried to
set the PID to negative one right on the
buffers I mean I see why I did it this
way but that's kind of bad
right so this is essentially leaving
around garbage data in the observations
oh what we can do can't we just set the
whole thing to be
zero I think I can
right if I just do
um at the top of compute observations if
I just do was it self.
player
and it's a little
awkward and it's a little
awkward cu the player ID is needs to be
negative
one well we'll leave it like this for
now
um it'd be really nice if I didn't have
to number them from zero
but is there any way I can knock number
them from
player maybe I can number them from
one right if I if I'm so I'm basically
always going to be getting players with
a get player function reason for having
the getter is it prevents you from
screwing up pointers uh there's a really
easy way to screw up and copy the data
by mistake do a deep copy of the data
here
so if
instead yeah what what I'd like to have
happen is I'd like the indicator of
there's no player here to be player ID
equal to um one instead of Zero no no no
other way around so it's zero instead of
negative one maybe I'll do that so
self. player
OBS minus
one if I do like this
right and I number them
from1 then this equal to zero uh this
will also set the pids to zero so I can
delete
this which is very nice
one well this this Loop is going to be
slightly obnoxious is the one thing
because
okay so I need to I need to change some
stuff here I
think this is what I get for writing 500
lines of garbage code
right so this has got to be
PID and then it's one numb
agents plus
one get entity of PID
but then you have observations like this
the slicing gets worse
shoot yeah having pit index one indexed
is going to be awkward as well they're
both awkward
obnoxious I'll leave it as negative one
I've done this as in projects
before yeah I wanted to be able to save
that little bit of annoyance but uh
there's not really an easy way to do
okay um is there a way at least I can
set all of them at the same
time I don't think
here right so you get the player
here now we set the observations to be
this grid
thing then what is all this mess down
here
holy all right
so this is the targeting stuff so this
is up here you're seeing what is nearby
on the grid and you're putting this into
observations and this giant mess of code
here is checking all of the tiles and
extracting data from
those
range it's really gross code isn't
it and so hard to refactor stuff like
this cuz I see why I did it but it's
just gross
so get player get player
OB uh this the one nice thing about this
is I no longer have to do these
checks because uh I changed the type to
entity
so I can uh just a I have a generic
entity type that has the same data so I
can do
this that's slightly
better but this is still really
gross let's come back to this and clean
up some other
stuff how's our spawn function
work do we use this
function no we don't use this this is a
dead code from previous project I used
his starter
code okay so now we get to the reset
function this is going to be an entity
star player and we're going to get
entity
star do we need
yeah we do need entity
star entity Star Tower
okay uh and then let's not let's just
write them out one per line in y
x so we get player
I set the PID the health the max
Health all
that if I is less
than num agents over
two okay so this is manually positioning
players and then I add them to the PID
map I don't add them to the grid
though I don't think we should be
manually touching the PID map here I
think we should be using the using the
move to function
right yeah this one
here
so self dot move
to we're going to move the PID which is
I and we're going to move it to
spawn
y
right player. spawn X and then this will
take care of all of this including the
grid and the pit
map we want to be touching the idea here
is that we have these low uh these
underlying data structures in this
environment we have like these 2D maps
that tell you uh they give you the
player ID at a specific location which
which makes it very efficient to look up
what players are nearby you right you
don't have to go through all the players
you just have to go through the nearby
set of tiles and look for pids that are
put into that data structure um but the
downside to this is now you have to
maintain all these data structures in
sync and like if you let's say you move
a player but you forget to move their
player ID which is in one of these data
structures now stuff gets desynced so in
order to avoid that what we want to do
is we want to like only
put that information in the move
function and maybe a few other limited
areas so that uh we limit the surface of
of places where we can make errors here
particularly when I'm half
too I guess you do do you do tower. move
to
right self. move
to where's the pit on
this this is I
I think I want I I think I want
PID because I'm going to reuse this
variable
PID and now this is
PID
PID we're going to move PID yeah that
that's cleaner and then it's going to
allow us to
do PID plus equal
this uh technically this would be a good
spot to just use some python LS for
these variables I don't
know what do we set we set team health
max Health damage
function
Tower and PID
tier into Y and
X something like
this so C
def
Tower equals get Tower of
PID and then you do tower.
team then you move it to Y and X yeah
that's good
and
um we'll just put some conditionals
here if tier is
zero tier is one tier is two well it's
tier one two or three
right so you have your tier one your two
two two three
else invalid tier all right so this will
clean it up and this will like this will
save us a bunch of annoying lines here
so all we do is Tower or what self.
spawn
Tower uh what did this give me 0
014 PID
team
YX so this is uh the only difference is
I need this PID to be
PID plus one I think
yeah this is pit +
one spawn Tower pit plus
two and we give it what this one
two no this is the tier it's a tier uh
tier one
7455 plus three
so there are your tier ones this is now
a tier
two
so we put the tier two
in uh did this just make up a random
position that makes no sense hold on did
it do it before no
10496 we just have to be careful
checking the suggestions from this
good 10666 tier 2 hey link key didn't
see you
yesterday welcome we're doing
mobas I don't know if you saw this
yesterday but this is what we got in uh
two days you can move the perer around
with the mouse and you can attack
stuff um yeah you can attack stuff you
can you have a couple skills pretty
basic but nice little
MOA demo now I'm cleaning up the code
and then we're probably going to do
creepy AI
right yeah this is the first tier this
is the uh the tier three now
okay had to watch the VOD I missed
yesterday looking forward to that I hope
you're not watching these just massive
rambling Dev
vods literally just me sitting down
working all
day I do wish I were putting longer
hours in but the the running is just
kicking my
ass what else is there to do at work oh
yeah fair
enough yeah I know your
work
is it's going to be easier to just write
this out isn't
it
so I'm going to hope that super Maven
gets this for me
because this is it's going to be team
one and then you do 128 minus 128
minus how fast do you run when you run
10 miles plus I'm incred incredibly
incredibly slow I think it was like 12
and a half minutes or something today
which is even slower than
normal hold
on but the thing is it's not flat it's
also not flat
um I've done where is it yeah so this is
1100 feet elevation gain um where's
this okay okay it is well I think this
is adjusted Pace or something right
wait there's
a 11 no it says
11:58 that might not be including
walking time I don't
know I'd have to check but
anyways yeah this
is you can see that there are like
sections where I've like had to walk or
whatever that are really slow and then
the running sections are are a little
bit
better I'm pretty chunky for running
though as well I currently weigh
um I weigh like 180 now
so
chunky I think this is what we want
right this is what I was hoping super
Maven would
do yep
perfect
oops so we just
uh spawn the towers like
this
that's a little nicer we're already down
like a 100 lines of
code uh now we have move
two averaging like 13 or 14 minute miles
per long distances yeah that the long
distances are are rough I
did the last marathon I did was
4 I think 447 or something so I got sub
five
um I forget what the pace is on that I
think it's like close to 11 flat or
something I don't know I've got some
somewhat better short distance
times get
player so these are
fine and I guess that I do want to have
the grid be like this
right let's
do uh in agent
type and then I want to do agent type is
Agent One
agent agent
two
agent type I don't know that's just
cleaner to
me and we can now put this down here so
we have the grid adjustment we've got
the pit
adjustment yeah that's better so this is
up update on grid update on pit Map
update player position and then we've
got the check to make sure that you're
not moving into something that is
obstacle respawn
is also pretty basic it just heals you
as well hold on let me turn the AC off
okay so this one
here uh this is where we have to start
adding entity type I believe
right yeah this is where we have to
start adding entity type
so let's
add
int um
entity I don't think you can just can
you do type or is it g to oh you can
totally do a
type
okay and then we'll just do uh what like
in
entity uh player zero entity creep
entity Tower right
player
hpe too figure out how to copy
all so here what we do is we set the
player.
type player. type is going to be entity
player and then when you do spawn
oh
jeez
man when we do spawn Tower we also have
to do is it tower.
type entity
Tower okay so
now now it's easy because when we go
to attack stuff we don't have this
really awkward check against the PID um
in fact we don't even have to do any
check at all just yet because all we we
do is we just check if target. team
because they all have team is not equal
to player team
right then you're going to subtract
damage so this
is okay and then we do if Target health
and it's a
player then we respawn the
is we do have to actually do one thing
for the
tower uh so
kill we need to
do no not this it's you don't need the
entity we need self.
grid no we wait we do need that okay
okay so we need the
entity C
def then we do y
x and then what we do is we do self.
grid is
empty and then self. PID map is negative
okay and I'm going to put this kill
function perfect right next to the move
function
I really just want to avoid having to do
manual grid and pit
manipulation
so this is if Target type is entity
player
else if it's a tower you kill
it and it's nested right it's fairly
nested but it's
simple
right uh and
actually we can make this even easier
because we can do if it's equal to the
team then we
return right because we don't need to do
anything and then we can actually just
continue this pattern right we can do if
Target health is greater than zero
return okay
okay
nice H leave it like this so we just
unnested this entire thing by since it's
in the attack function and this is all
it has to do we can just do these early
returns and now we have this whole
function flat this is much much better
code
I guess you could technically argue the
nesting is also kind of
fine it's actually been bothering me
less and less lately just having super
nested stuff
yeah this isn't bad either though
I like the idea of putting the PID up
top before the C defs because you don't
have to check anything right if um you
don't have to like waste any allocations
need so actually because we made this
entity thing we can
simplify we no longer
care what the type of the target is we
simply do
Target self. get
entity of the target
PID and then we get uh the target is
going to be get y and
x and then we go in the vicinity of Y
and
X Target pit is pit
map why did you switch to using entities
uh if you see how much simpler it's made
the code you'd get it um we've basically
there are lots and lots of times in the
code where we don't necessarily care
what type of entity a thing is we just
care that it is an entity in the game
and that can be resolved later so like
attack for instance right I would have
to make different attacks for uh
entities like for towers and for creeps
and for everything even though they're
all essentially the same code because
it's strongly typed and we don't have
like no Union types or whatever like
that so what I do is by having an entity
type you can check stuff like the pit
and the position and then if you
actually really need to know what you're
dealing with you can just check uh
entity. type like I do here target. type
and it's just this little tiny block of
code uh also this is better for
reinforcement learning because it's
going to allow us to put all of the
entity data in one big flat buffer which
is going to make the uh the network Ford
calls uh way easier to
parallelize so it works uh for multiple
different reasons
here if I were building a full scale
game I probably wouldn't do
this but for a project of this scope
it's very very nice and also I don't
build full scale games I build small and
midsize projects so this is
and look how nicely this works right we
didn't need we don't need to know
anything about what we're attacking
until inside of the attack function get
right here we don't have to do any
branching logic it works very
nicely this would
be uh this would kind of be the same as
if you're looking at like objectoriented
right uh design this would be like
having a base entity class and having
like sub classes for player and other
stuff um and then having the function
take an entity instead of like a
specific player uh and using like an
interface but we can also just bypass
all that Shenanigans and do it this way
and it's it's the same
thing so yeah it's
fun it's kind of kind of funny how you
get the exact same patterns of
development in like well this is
essentially c
um and it sometimes ends up just being
simpler like yeah there's been so much
progress made but not really we just see
is
simple and scon is convenient C
Tower okay so we potentially still need
um
we potentially still need these get
functions though to give us the
offsets
Towers get
Tower if the tower is
dead we
continue otherwise we go
through the tower's Vision range
pid1
continue and then we do
um Target is going to be you get
entity if Target type is entity Tower or
not equal to entity player rather no
wait it's entity Tower
so if the tower sees another Tower
continue okay now we know we're
targeting a player
right target. team is Tower team you
continue and
uh we do attack
right attack pit Target damage
cleaner are there any videos on getting
started with using neural
MMO um I mean my thesis is a good
outline of everything that is there um
in the platform there's also there's the
Discord and stuff where you can ask
questions it it's integrated with puffer
lib which is nice uh it should work with
puffer 10 so you should just be able to
run it from there there and uh we do
have more neural MMO stuff coming out as
well so I have not I'm not fully done
with with the project there's one
additional thing I have planned for
neural MMO that should be done very
soon I would start playing around with
uh with it and puffer 10 for now though
that's the easiest way to do
it thank
you there's going to be a lot more RL
for me now that I've graduated because
basically all the time that I would
spent have spent on like academic stuff
papers you know experiments for the
purpose of papers know thinking about
that stuff it's all going into building
good good RL and good RL tools now so
things are happening
quickly and I'm having a much better
time of it
recently finished my masters and looking
for another project there's so much cool
stuff uh in and around RL these days um
obviously everything around puffer is
open source we welcome contributors if
you have like specific environments you
want to make and add or like just add
bindings for if you have ideas for
experiments on stuff um yeah there's a
lot in and around this area that is uh
that's
available solving net hack is definitely
something I want to see it's very very
hard um I did make it very fast though I
did make net hack very fast you can now
Run net hack vectorized at close to
100,000 steps per second with puffer
actually this is a really nice demo of
puffer's capabilities so I'll
just let me just show you how important
puffer is for something like net
hack right by the way this paper got
rejected from nurs and from RLC uh so
we'll just see how ridiculous that is
when you see this
table
so okay here's net hack
you know net hack mini
hack
um if you vectorize with
gymnasium it runs 7,000 steps per second
if you re vectorize with sp3 it runs
6,000 steps per second if you vectorize
with puffer lib it runs 96,000 steps per
second that seems rather useful doesn't
it
yeah I am uh I'm not going to the
conference this year at least I haven't
I've got no plans to um the first
reviewer that rejected my or the first
review on my paper was by an llm that
fabricated typos uh that were not in my
paper so it just basically said hey look
this sloppy paper look at all these
typos typos were not in the paper it was
made up by an LM and that was not good
enough for us second look at the paper
apparently that was not a sufficient
reason I'm done with
Academia dumb
game you got the same thing on one of
your reviews about a confabulated
typo it was probably the same guy and I
sent RLC like four emails asking that
okay if you're not going to you know
overturn this which you really should
but if you're not going to overturn this
can you at least offer some guarantee
that you're going to like you should
contact the University of this reviewer
if it's some dumb grad student who just
signed up to review like they should be
expelled for this if I did that at MIT
if I just like submitted fabricated
reviews within a language model I would
expect to Beed that's sabotaging
somebody's work but no they won't tell
me anything
so completely disappointed with the way
that they handled that um I was really
really rooting for RLC and you know I
know Eugene Eugene's awesome uh there
are a lot of good people trying to make
it work but if you there this type of
bureaucracy is going to be involved then
I throw up my hands I can't do
anything and I'm not going to spend my
time and money to go to a conference
where I don't even get to present my
poster
right not going to like go across the
country just to like show up and not be
able to get my work out
there poster sessions are usually really
really good for me I'm pretty loud um so
like the neural MMO won last year at
NPS we handed out and 3 hours we handed
out like 400 promo cards for uh neural
MMO and talked to at least that many
people probably you know probably more
five like five or 600
fine it's really cool to see the um the
support on the stream here what are your
plans now these are my plans now I'm
working full-time on Puffer
um puffer is technically a company
although all of our stuff is free and
open source um it has no revenue or
anything at the moment but my goal is to
just fix reinforcement learning first
and hopefully if some companies start
using it they'll want support contracts
and other things that will let me uh you
know fund the thing bootstrap it that
way uh but for the time being I'm really
just focused on how do I make RL
actually work you know that's been my
whole thing
[Music]
it's been going very very well the
growth has been absolutely nuts
like here this is when I this is when I
started uh working on puffer full-time
right
here I've been slacking in the last few
days I got to keep promoting it go ahead
and star this it uh helps me out a whole
ton good shot of accomplishing that yeah
thank you I'd hope so
um rl's such a mess right now it really
just needs to be it needs to be fixed
and it's it's a doable thing it's very
doable simulators like this are going to
help a lot because you're going to be
able to run your experiments like 100 to
a thousand times faster than previously
good discretize here discretization is
fine exactly what I've been looking for
hey I hope it's I hope it's helpful and
you know I'm not I'm not making any
money off of this at the moment so I'm
not paying anybody for this yet but my
hope is that once perer at least gets
some reasonable revenue and I'm not
taking VC funding for it by the way that
just gives me more problems than it
solves um but once puffer hopefully gets
some Revenue I'd like to be posting some
substantial open source bounties around
this stuff for folks but know that's
going to have to wait until this
actually gets off the
ground already put a fair bit of cash
into the um the puffer cluster
I do sponsor okay there is one thing
that I do sponsor at the moment thanks
for the star appreciate it helps me a
whole ton um I do sponsor compute for
stuff now most of this is currently
going to Pokemon which is the main open
source project that I'm uh sponsoring at
the moment I think these five boxes are
all in Pokemon
um but for people who stick around and
are doing good work and just want like a
little bit of extra compute to do stuff
with I do Grant access to uh the puffer
cluster for that it's only eight really
good boxes for now um My Hope Is this is
like a there's a whole post on it it's
like this is a $35,000 cluster My Hope
Is that once puffer gets some Revenue I
can build this out to like a $200,000
cluster or something which would give me
enough machines to actually power a
substantial number of Open Source
projects um but that's going to have to
wait a little longer a whole tear down
on this as well I set all this up myself
link is one of our uh contributors on uh
Pokemon he's been doing awesome stuff
over there
oh speaking of which somebody asked me
somebody on that project asked me for a
reference
good so we've got
movement got velocity
I think this is way cleaner
already well obviously there's some more
to do here and see if I can see any
attacks and then this
is
oops
players um this should not be agent idx
I think that this should be hid
right
pit is Agent 9x
PID
what else is there to fix in
here we also don't need oh this is Tower
idx because this is not a
PID
good we have the attack function looks
way better respawn looks way better kill
looks way better move to is
good the N is a little sketchy but it's
going to be hard-coded mostly anyways
because um
well it's going to mostly end up having
to be hardcoded regardless right because
the positions are hard-coded for now
this will get better in the
future spawn Tower function is fine this
should be a cdef cdef
void we don't need this Tower Y and
Tower X because that's what move two
does saves us a little bit
and really the only thing that's still
kind of gross is this compute
observations function up here right oh
we also typo this
entity
entity Tower this is an idx not a
PID and this is actually plus numb agent
not
minus
so this function right here uh this
function is incredibly important so for
reference when you design a Sim like
this this function here is usually like
at least half if not 80% of the compute
because if you think about it pretty
much the whole rest of the logic it
isn't doing very much right like you're
checking a few conditions you're Maybe
uh incrementing or decrementing some
variables um but you're not really doing
any big data copies or anything right
and for the most part there aren't any
there aren't even any huge Loops like
the actual amount of processing that an
agent has to do every step is very very
small that is the trick to having uh
really good Sims is having stuff that is
interesting but doesn't need to do a lot
of compute per agent step now the one
exception is it's always difficult to
compute observations because you need to
copy the data for the observations into
whatever buffer it is per agent there's
no way to do it as a simple slice um
there's always at least a copy and if
you're doing anything non-trivial like
we're doing here we have some data that
needs to be moved around usually and
computed dynamically so in this case we
have a simple slice right here this is
telling us just like the obstacle map
this is like a low a low dimensional map
that just says where are the walls
you're going to run into and stuff like
that and then we have this here which is
Computing uh a set of like the 10
nearest agents to the current
fast this is what decides whether this
environment runs 100,000 steps per
second or 10 million steps per second is
how simple we can make the computation
of observations
there's going to be some Shenanigans I
can do to do this in one step I don't
know how to do it right now can I at
least clean up the
Loops well this is redundant this check
here is redundant
this check here is
good I actually think it would be better
down here it is both cleaner and
slightly faster because we break out of
the loop early uh this was not actually
redundant I'm
dumb
H that's quite
obnoxious needing to have these two
separate check
wait no you need two separate trucks
that
yeah I can put it at the bottom like
this at least then you have your break
and break like that
okay
well it's not perfect but I think that
this is way better than it was before
we'll fix some
bugs and um we'll see how this goes from
here it's at least 100 line shorter than
before
PID we just have to add some oops no
wait we had Target pit was
defined entity star
Target target.
PID let's look for player
ah right here so this is
entity
layer
time maybe we have more errors up here
that we can fix first
fix entity cannot convert entity star to
python object is very
message okay so we do have some Tower
stuff left in here this entity
self. num agents is players.
shape right there is no players it's
just
entities uh which we actually we don't
know this anymore we need to pass this
information this is now has to
be like shoot there's a lot of stuff int
num agents num creeps num
Towers probably something like
this agents
Towers cannot take the address of a
python
object okay so we forgot to assign uh
right here
this is lowercase e entities that's
probably where most of the bugs are
coming
from
there according to this there's still a
lot of
right so let's go fix
that uh this is self. entities not
Towers cannot convert long to memory
view
is how to zero data we figure out how to
zero all this data
121 so this really should be a
PID right
here this is a PID
be
okay Target is get player Target
progress cannot convert entity star to
python
object that's very
weird get player
OB
OB did I Define this function
weirdly uh there's player
OBS it's I do have a player OBS defined
here do I have it defined up here I do I
have this entity map
player
OBS is set
here and is defined up
there okay so I don't know why that
is and when you get player Target
PID it's the same thing over and over
right entity
well this one's
easy these are like all the same
error Let Me Clear get one more of this
cannot convert entity star to python
[Music]
no self doop players anywhere
okay I thought that there might be like
a built-in entity or something but
no no built-in
this target pit is defined
right yeah it's an
INT so it's target.
PID and Target is is get player
OB player OB which is a fully typed
star which is from player
OBS and player
OBS is defined here as a 2d entity
map can convert struct pointer let me
just Google
it has some python data structures to C
code thats
pointers well first of all I don't think
I am trying to pass them to python on
um is it because of these extras that I
have up
here I'm actually wondering if this is
screwing me I don't think so
because this wouldn't make sense to me
for this to affect anything
yeah no it's not these so we'll leave
these on because these are
player why does it say cannot convert to
python object it shouldn't have to
convert to a python object
that's like just so incredibly
obnoxious I think I had seen your
doctoral defense video where you had the
RL based MMO would that be you yep that
is me
welcome we're now building new projects
live or at the moment being stuck on
Arcane scon
bugs RL must be exercised
I'm trying to see if there are any clues
in
here this is a fun one to debug I feel
your
pain oh I've done way
worse I've done way worse than
this very nice presentation gave me some
good pointers in my research how's life
after PhD still stuck on scyon I
actually Love scyon syon Is Awesome scon
has let me do so much amazing stuff and
if you haven't seen my more recent
stuff we built this in a week it's 200
some odd lines of cython and 200 some
odd lines of python it's snake with 4096
snakes that runs at 14 million steps per
second on One Core one CPU core and it
trains at a million steps per second so
we've been doing ultra high performance
Sim we've been doing stuff with puffer
lip for compatibility with fancy
environments we've been doing um really
good hyper parameter sweep type work
with uh carbs and VI carbs
algorithm um lots and lots of stuff
around it the progress has been nuts I
think I've gotten more done in the last
two months than I've gotten done in the
last two years so that's very
nice generally having a lot more fun as
well nice being out of Academia
float is there like a
single bug in here that isn't all the
same
one unsafe C derivative of temporary
python reference
what is that get player
PID how is this a unsafe SE derivative
of a temporary python reference I have
player defined right here right it's an
entity
star I've
got there's not a single thing here that
is not defined in
derivative it's like it's not picking up
the struck def right did I mess this
struck def up
somehow C def
struct entity
me syon is like nine nine out of 10
there it's it's one of those things
where like I really wish that know some
of the people on the rust community that
are very very
intensively uh making memory safety a
thing which is like kind of
Niche would hop on over to something
like this and make like Ultra fast easy
interoperable with python really nice
syntax syon a little bit better they're
just a few rough edges still but you
stream there isn't a schedule I just
started this in the last few weeks but
um I've been doing this three to five
times a week
now just depending on what I have going
on I've been enjoying it and I get I
actually get more done like whenever I
have a day where i'm like too tired to
sit down and focus on something um and I
like distract myself cuz my thoughts
tend to wander a lot I'll just do stuff
on stream and I don't know I get like a
second
wind so it's good for people to be able
to see some cool stuff happening live I
get to meet some cool people some people
get interested in the open source St
people see puffer and I actually get
more done most of the
exceptions this is uh TR streamed as
well this is live on X YouTube and uh
twitch so for new folks here please go
ahead and star this repository Star
Puffer Leb uh this is the main source of
all my work helps me out a whole bunch
on this thing it gets uh as this thing
gets larger it just helps me out a whole
bunch I'd really like to not be fixing
the scon bug all
day um but I'm kind of just baffled as
to why
like I typed it right didn't I is it
like a
typo
no it looks correct to
me I would expect there to be a bug at
the top but like all the way up
here you already have on what
123 very first time I call get player
OB cannot convert entity star to python
object and cannot convert python object
to entity star
bizarre just to give me the opportunity
to feel incredibly stupid we're going to
ask chat GPT it's not going to know why
it's going to waste my time because it
always does um
but we'll do it
anyways are you streaming on Twitch by
chance yes I yes I am it's on uh
Twitter it's on Twitch Twitter and
YouTube also the one on X for whatever
reason is only
720p as far as I can tell X does not
support
1080p it
seems this is not going to work I'm
almost positive we're going to do it
anyways
I feel very stupid even attempting
this but maybe there's a
chance
see where is it Moa
what kind of mobile are we building here
oh wait I've got a couple things thanks
to the overview sounds really
interesting work you've done does this
work have a publication background that
can be
reviewed uh yes there is a a white
paper if you just look up poer li paper
archive it's right here so there's a
white paper on puffer Leb as well as all
of the stuff being open source so you
can literally go check it and you know
evaluate all the claims and stuff main
thing is really super fast uh CPU
vectorization compatibility with lots of
different types of environments and lots
of nice infrastructure all
around so that is there
um this project this m is two days old I
started this thing two days ago and to
give you an idea of how far it is since
I haven't run it in a
while this is where we ended
yesterday you can control this puffer
you can move it around with your
Mouse um you can control it with neuron
Nets as well you can attack stuff by
mousing over it there even a couple
skills that you can use pretty darn
basic mooba uh MOBA style thing but hey
there's a map there's some other puffers
at the start as well uh and we're going
to continue building out and hopefully
we're going to do some basic creep AI
today they were the other puffers so
that's where this is
now what kind of mobile are we building
here like a l DOTA sty yeah like that
but it's going to be mini it's going to
be like not that level of complexity
right the target size for this project
like I want the whole code for this to
be 1500 lines top something like that I
can do a lot in 1500 lines but this is
supposed to be a small maybe midscale
project
um yeah this is something that I want to
have done like in you know couple weeks
of time not months
thank
you if you want to help my workout just
um drop the puffer repo a star it helps
me out a whole
function
returns expects a python but receives a
c type
pointer if you try to return an
directly in a
context but I'm calling this from
syon
that I don't think it's once ever
actually given me something helpful for
something like
this I guess these I can fix right
278 is this a
clue does this have to be like at the
bottom or
something
wait give me your
Twitch yeah
it's uh TT
do.tv jars
here did your prompt have the error you
were seeing had the first you know 50
lines of it at least it's a giant error
message um I do have a little bit of a
clue here I think
so it's saying that this is
not local variable Target was referenced
before
assignment
oh well yeah it is I didn't
freaking assign it
somehow how'd that
happen okay
okay maybe I am just
stupid I don't think that's all of it
though I think that's like one small bit
of
it okay so that gets rid of the warnings
from here so I no longer have any uh
unreferenced variable warnings here that
I can see but I still have this entity
conversion
warning so I mean this is a pretty nice
one to look
at so Target is get player Target pick
Target is defined here as an entity
star and then if I look at for void or
is what is it get
player wait is it
get oh my God stupid get into so
stupid so incredibly
stupid let's get entity
I really wish it would just tell you
that you're calling a function that
doesn't exist instead of spewing garbage
worst so dumb
okay let's
see now we have far fewer
errors get player
OB is this what it's still called it's
called get player OB
right entity star get player
OB player OB
self R compile does that yes but the
rust compiler also imposes worthless
borrow checks on everything that you
have to fight
so that doesn't help
me I mean I posted about this before
like look
I love the idea of there being a
programming language that gives you
really good low-level perf with lots of
nice tooling around it I hate the idea
of like randomly deciding that
everything needs to be borrow checked
for memory leaks when I'm literally not
malaking anything in this entire program
and the majority of the time if I am
allocating stuff I'm allocating it at
the start of the program and it's going
to be deallocated at the end of the
program and nothing else so that doesn't
help me whatsoever and also I hate the
idea of not being able to mix highle and
lowl code together easily so here I can
write python in here whenever I want
arbitrary Python and it'll just run
python speed but I can also write syon
in here and it'll run C- speed with
absolutely no friction between those
layers no like big fancy pbind API in
the middle of that this is why this is
awesome um yeah it doesn't have the same
level of Dev Community around it as
something like rust but rust is
definitely going to cause more problems
than
this I would try like zigg or something
first if I were going to do a different
language yeah pie bind is just God
awful syon means you don't have to go
through
that like you do not have to go through
pbind H if you use syon and it is the
only thing which you do not have to go
through um pbind h
what did I do wrong
here get player OB
right so this one is not named wrong I
can fix the other errors first I guess
I would not personally write high level
logic and rust yeah when writing drivers
are bare metal code I found it easier to
not shoot my yes and that's what it's
for right rust was written for systems
programming like that but I'm not
writing that right I'm writing high
performance uh
simulations and when you're doing high
performance simulation you better not be
doing any memory applications like they
should all be done up front and you
should be reusing memory so I actually
don't even have to do any Malo in this
code because what I do is all the memory
I need is in structured numpy arrays
that get passed into scon get populated
at c-speed with memory views in scon and
then that memory is mirrored back and
forth between them it's the same uh it's
the same address in memory
so I basically it is impossible for me
to have memory problems right so adding
additional
mandatory overhead um compile overhead
and additional syntax overhead is not
doing me any
favors like the defining feature of rust
is something that is fundamentally
harmful to what I'm
issue cuz you're using the
stack well you can use the Heap as well
if your memory is allocated at in it and
it's deallocated at the end of the
program right as long as you don't have
intermediate Heap allocations it's
fine but yeah you have a lot of memory
these days you can just put it all in
the stack
does cython still run the the GC nope
not inside of um pure C blocks so the
way it works is if you only write um C
compatible operations it does not call
back to python whatsoever and you can
check that uh there's a tool that you
can use to check
that so the python side will run the
garbage collector right but then all the
loops and stuff in syon will be super
fast and there is nothing to garbage
collect because you're not using the uh
you're not using the python
allocator like there there's nowhere
that anything's being allocated
entity index should be typed for more
efficient
access int
disk
y so this is going to be disk y dis X
right
typed how's it telling me that index
should be
typed
duh it's interesting it's a way to hand
off performant blocks directly to C
instead of interpreting them yeah
exactly I haven't used syon before but
be got to be careful about memory
allocations then I guess well you don't
do them like
look oops if I look for Malik there's no
Malik and it's not like you're not like
doing memory allocations in here under
the hood anywhere like there just aren't
any so there's literally nowhere that
you're you can possibly go wrong
here like all the memory here all the
memory for the program is passed
in like this environment survives the
lifetime of the program all the memory
for it is right here it's this giant
this giant array entities which is going
to be Memory viewed as a bunch of
structs player OBS observations like
this is all
it there's no other memory that's being
used like this is a numpy array right
this entities is a numpy array
well I'm going to view this
as a fixed length array of structs
without making any new allocations it's
just a way you're just like view casting
the
bytes and there's very nice Syntax for
doing that um yeah
PD Target do I have Target defined
here I do have Target defined
here and that is cleared after it leaves
the scope so it's memory managed um well
no but it's that memory is backed by
numpy Rays so it's cleared when it goes
out of scope on the python side but it
never does go out of scope because that
is your simulator like this is for
reinforcement learning the simulator is
going to stay alive for the lifetime of
the program anyways so yeah when the
program exits python will clean it up
for you with its slow garbage collector
but that's it like there's no there are
no slow there no potent there's no
potential for memory leaks and there's
no nothing that is slow that actually
matters if it's
slow I mean like I said the snake
environment and actually several of the
other environments I've built run at
over 10 million steps per second single
core with really really brain dead brain
dead easy code as
well why is this one not happy
Target is get entity of
PID PID is an
INT oh was PID not defined no pit is
defined pid's right
here so targets get entity of
PID and going check target.
def cannot convert entity star to python
object
and Target pit is defined as well right
target pit is an INT yep Target pit is
an
INT very
weird looking for Clues here as to
what's
wrong this target. pit is having uh
oh
it's I took pit out of the data struct I
took pit out of the struct that's
why I wish it would give you a
reasonable error message
jeez like struct doesn't have that
element PID
maybe that's
awful syon isn't perfect it's pretty
good not perfect this is stuff that
could easily be picked up though by a
better compiler right like this is just
lack of lack of tooling around
any hopes for Mojo when it comes to
GPU
um for stuff like that
I I wait for it to stand the test of
time I'm not going to invest my time in
like some company's own programming
language thing where they've made like a
bunch of not exactly good faith
benchmarks that like really
exaggerate performance
differences um
if they make something good and it
stands and it stands up for a couple
years then I'll look at it um but
they've made some weird decisions with
it that I don't particularly like so I
don't have huge I don't have a hugely
high hopes for
it I also don't think you're going to be
able to write simulators on the GPU like
you're just not going to be able to
write like con like full-fledged
simulators uh with any level of simplic
on the
GPU there's a lot of sequential
processing there's no way to just write
arbitrary code and have it run fast on
the GPU that's what CPUs are
for I think that the puffer stack is
better for that it's you know have
simple highper simulators on CPU and
have really good vectorization to get
that data onto GPU fast
oh one thing that actually would really
help quite a bit is if there were a way
to
um have memory that is both shared
shared memory and also
pinned um that would be really nice
there's not currently a way to do that
and that's one of the reasons why GPU
transfer is slow right now
okay so you do actually have to have the
PID in the data structure for now that's
fine
yeah so player. PID is equal to
PID spawn
[Music]
Tower uh I think I've seen that channel
in my
recommendations I think it's more basic
and educational though isn't
was like the purposes of what I'm doing
here is not like this is not necessarily
educational content by Design This Is Me
doing research live and it just happens
to be educational which is nice um but
it's not the primary goal like I'm not
spending time on making this a good
educational resource other than just
answering questions I'm spending time on
like trying to make all the RL mess of
the field fixed which will then make it
easier for beginners yeah but it'll also
make it easier for
everybody yeah it's definitely good to
have channels like that around though
for uh for newcomers to RL for sure uh I
personally I don't have the experience
with animations I don't have like web
dev experience to put stuff online for
like live demos so um
it doesn't really make sense for me to
be trying to go that route when I can
like make these these Sims
here okay well this actually finally
compiled so that took way more time than
I wanted it to this morning but uh now
we're actually going to be able to run
this as soon as I fix some bugs on the
python side I think and uh then we're
going to actually be able to start on
the creep AI today so that's
awesome first thing
yeah I honestly that wasn't even that
dumb on my part like the reason that was
hard was that I had really bad and
misleading compiler
yeah
so I need to not have C players I need c
entities right so it's C entities
and this is going to be numb agents plus
self. Nom Towers I think so self. num
Towers it's 18 Towers nine per
side
and OBS players gives this is fine
creeps will leave uh we'll get rid of
this for now actually we don't need this
dtype is now entity D type since we
merged these D types very very close to
having this working
I see the view the view counts gone up
quite a bit so welcome new folks you
wouldn't mind giving the puffer liba
star if you find this useful helps me
out a whole ton other than that enjoy
the
dev
um let's
grab entity D
type don't need Tower D
type uh we do kind of want to
have do we want to have towers as a
separate thing or do we not need it I
think we probably don't need it
right
so actions
observations let's start running it and
then uh we'll just debug from
here is it
oops
python demo
and MOA mode e render mode
human I am actually kind of tempted to
uh to dip my toes a little bit into
webdev just to see if there's like some
really dumb easy way I could get some of
these environments on line but from what
I've seen I don't think that there's
going to be uh I don't think that there
is going to be a way to do
wouldn't be super straightforward you'd
have to look into wasm so here's the
cool thing rib here which is what I'm
using for rendering uh natively supports
wasum but I think it's only this it's
only the C bindings or the C version of
rib that supports it so I would have to
write the render client in C which is
kind of gross and then I would also need
to have some sort of like socket server
uh to run the python code server side
unless I get all the python running on
the client side which is
harder can puffer make use of web
GPU technically if I wrote the clients
on um if I wrote the clients in C using
the same API everything's the same just
the render client in C then yes I think
so um yeah web dev slows you down
sometimes be great to pick up things
like you're unable to work if you're
like really yeah that's the thing I
think it really would slow me down and
like I have zero tolerance for like
complicated and overbuilt stacks like I
only I will exclusively work with simple
tools because I just I know myself I get
incredibly bored whenever Dev speed
slows down because you have a clunky
stack um so the most valuable thing for
me is to be able to keep up my pace of
work so that I Stay interested otherwise
it gets slowed down even more than you
would expect is just the way I
work it's one of the reasons I've gotten
so bored of like experimental side work
right because you just spend so much
time like thinking about what
experiments to run running experiments
you don't actually get to just build
stuff okay so now we're actually at the
point
where we get
the uh the signature to fix we have to
fix the
signature and then I think it should be
pretty close to
working I know maybe if I got to find
somebody that does a bunch of webd to
like see if there's actually anything
that's remotely like fast and easy to
use these days um like something I kind
of want something that's like rib for
web right which is really really basic
and really low level
getting a website outsourced is pretty
cheap these days it's about maintaining
it that's the hard part right I don't
like I want to be able to put these Sims
so you could play them online against
other like against RL agents that would
be cool I I don't know if there's an
easy way to do
that this takes entities OBS
players uh OBS view
rewards and then here we need self. Nom
agents self. Nom creeps
self.
Nom
Towers
oops let's split this
here okay so and I need to set num
creeps I think CU we're not using it yet
but um
yeah what num it
sure okay so we have a few other things
apparently that I broke in the process
of
refactor idx
plus num agents
um get
Tower so spawn Tower
is yes so this
is idx not PID
idx and then tower.
PID is going to
be plus num agents I think
kind of
sketch and when you spawn the tower in
this
index would the IDE hold on uh would the
idea that be that people are using your
GP or theirs multiplayer single player
with ourends I don't know how you would
make it if you wanted them to use their
GPU they'd have to be running the Python
and the scon stack locally I don't think
you like I don't think it's easy to get
all that running on web if you can run
arbitrary Python and scon on web then
sure otherwise I don't know how server
side agent management protocol with
rendering on the client and socket
connection to each session yeah that's
the problem main hitch being sync
between different web
clients yeah it it's hard right and it's
like it's hard on a bunch of stuff that
doesn't even help the fundamentals of RL
so like I don't really think it's worth
doing oh wait no it's the other way
around here
right so this is like
zero
one oh I don't want to let it auto
correct I'm going to do do this manually
cuz I don't trust
it oops three
four oops let's just do in batch like
this
oops
nope
there be more for accessibility yeah I
know and accessibility is important but
it's like it's not in my current skill
set and like I have a bunch of stuff
that I can actively do that's making the
field way like that's improving the
field so I mean maybe down the line
somewhere
but that's such a pain
what is syon anyways I only see python
code uh does python have types like this
python have
pointers it's kind of nice though that
you see
um it's kind of funny though that you
see uh only python code because that's
the point cython is just very close to
python but it runs c-s speed so there
you
go why not put spawn Tower in a loop how
do you put spawn Tower in a loop I'd
have to
there's all these different positions
I'd have to just like you see they take
all different
arguments so I think that you'd end up
with a bunch of branching logic like
it's I don't see a way of putting this
in a loop that's simpler than hard
coding it with all these arguments that
they take that are different
yeah it's just that they're like they're
not randomly generated Towers right it's
a MOA so it's it's like their fixed game
assets it is C with python syntax fair
to say kind of so the cool thing with
python uh with scon is that you can
write arbitrary Python and it'll be slow
or you can use like slightly different
data types and stuff and it'll run
c-speed so it allows you to effortly mix
in C with python syntax and python which
is really
nice if they're static you won't need a
loop yeah there's no there static
there's no
do differing
extents it's obnoxious
player. X
and player.
Y pit is get
entity
zero on are these zero I bet these are
zero print RC
I'm starting to severely regret limiting
myself to one coffee per
day okay so right
here this is the issue it's at 0 but
well hold on 1 2 3
wait
two three four five six seven eight nine
okay so the 10th one is wrong
um off by one
error yeah off by one
[Music]
power PID
is idx plus self. nade wait this is
fine not not by one
error there would be 10
agents so this is getting overwritten
somewhere um
somewhere range of numb agents this is
zero through
nine
7266 where is it 66
if it's less than numb agent so wait one
two three four five yeah they're five on
this
team and then this other
team this one is getting overwritten it
looks like
right
so it's got to be in spawn
Tower uh which has PID of it's zero but
then if I do get
Tower
it's get Tower of
zero get
somehow the last uh the last agent isn't
getting spawned
correctly okay
so
10 27 this is correct so this Tower it
doesn't look like the tower is
overriding the uh the spawn
okay I also really wish that pdb worked
in scon I guess there technically side
debug you should really start learning
to use
that print debugging is really
lame anything
useful 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7even
nine so here's the last player getting
spawned oh I wonder if I overrode a pit
or something let me see maybe compute
observations itself
is I wouldn't put it if uh I wouldn't
put it past myself to have forgotten
that
so first of all idx
here so idx gets set to
zero wait get
player a pit is NE this is fine and
then you get the
entity you have this
position and then this is it's already
failing here but it could be failing
here because I overwrote something down
here
so idx
kid I'm not overwriting
PID I am overwriting DX but I should be
allowed to do that
RNC I am overriding RNC but again I
should be allowed to do
that Target
PID you get the
entity and then you set
the target
OB Target OB is from get player OB this
is
fine H I don't see it
well I could comment this just to
see that would tell me for sure right if
I have something oops if I have
something screwed up here this would
tell me
okay so I the fact that I still get the
bug means
um that it's not
this so somewhere I'm uh I'm probably
overwriting something
check looks like wasam Pi build lets you
compile a syon file into web assembly
and you can
serve the wasm file by embedding it
into the HTML of your
awesome yeah if it actually works that's
awesome now the thing that would be
weird about that right is you should be
able to if you can compile a scon file
scon lets you write arbitrary python so
you would have to be able to build
python into wasm which I don't know how
that would work um
but yeah if you get if you can get like
a very basic um like scyon type EnV with
um a RB front end working in the web let
me know cuz that would be that would be
amazing to be fair that's the type of
thing I'd like to put an open source
bounty on but we're not doing those
until puffer gets Rev
right we were
checking to see if I overwrote PID
somewhere uh step function would be a
good candidate for that
right so I'm I'm writing PID
here but that's
fine
maybe maybe
here I don't see anywhere where I'm
setting pit directly though
right yeah there's nowhere that I'm
setting PID directly
let's see if it fails in reset or if it
fails well actually I should be able to
see
right no it fails earlier it fails in a
reset this waste of time it fails it
does fail in
reset
weird Okay so let's just let let's
comment all the spawn Towers
oops
215 perfect timing I will finish
this I will uh make myself a shake take
a couple
minutes and uh then we'll do the creep
AI once that'll be the timeline for
today differing
extents can comment well right now all
the spawn
towers do not
work computer observation still messes
yeah
oops let's comment all the spawn towers
and some stuff in computer observations
idx no this is this looks fine actually
let's just let's uh comment this as well
differing extents and dimension
zero still doesn't work
get entity on
PID new slice
right is it possible that the move to
thing isn't working
okay so this one says 0
7266 oh it's possible that I'm on a
piece of terrain
right I didn't check
that it's possible the SP the spawn
cords are just
bad let me check that
let's
say
62 60 what
this oh wait
what hold
on yeah this is fine so it's 64 plus pit
let's let's try this
okay that was
it boom okay apparently um I was
spawning an agent I was overwriting like
the one pixel on the wall before so I
didn't notice it um but when I
refactored the move code I explicitly
made it so that you know under no
circumstance ances can you teleport into
a wall and I didn't realize that I was
spawning the agents on a
wall medium stupid
probably a good idea to have a return
type that states that
issue
um so the thing is it's cuz I have the
spawn positions
hardcoded and
I'm I have it duct taped in a way the
reason that this could happen at the
moment at all is because I have it duct
taped in away where the spawn
functions
um I've got it duct taped in a way where
like the spawn functions are
hardcoded uh
and this is not going to be
possible well this should not be
possible once I change it to be like
spawned randomly in a spawn Zone cuz I'm
just going to check for the tiles in
there I don't know what a good way to
check for it for now would be I'd have
to write a separate
routine okay so this is
now Bill observations stre
there's no Towers right you need to
do entities
Towers hold
on
client this is now entities
it's funny that I get to take a break
from my research by looking at yours hey
whatever floats your
what Target
PID I think it's just
oh it's always going to be entities of
PID entities is entities of
PID
okay here is the
puffer why is it getting like completely
merked can I I
like why is it getting killed
constantly presumably the uh The Entity
checks are wrong somewhere because it
shouldn't be getting merked
constantly yeah even when I'm spamming
heal it still
get player OB with PID and
attack the target pit is equal to
target. pit
it's like it's getting collided instant
it's not collided it's getting killed
instantaneously um now I'm wondering if
I do get
player OB or compute observations
maybe I am setting the
PID I am setting the target's PID here
so it should be able to to get the
target
pit it's possible it's wrong for
Towers but this looks good to
me yeah this looks good to
me and we're assigning it correctly for
agents I would hope
right let me
see yeah we are assigning the PID right
here to player
and move
to hold
on uh you
know I'm realizing with the tower no
wait Tower this is correct I did use the
correct pit for the tower I didn't use
the index by mistake
this is why the pit system kind of
sucks I don't have a better alternative
though
spawn is it y comma
X it's y comma X
right
this looks
fine The
Entity attack target.
PID well I can verify quickly whether
it's the towers that are misfiring or
the Players let's see if I still get
merked by
um if this if I still get merked when I
do this
okay still getting merked
instantly why is there a puffer there
where there's supposed to be a
tower oh I just didn't update the
renderer that's
fine uh let's see if I get merked
when I comment the player attacks no I
can't comment the whole player block
let's see if I get merked when I comment
the
player
attacks just this
block right
okay so I do not get merked
immediately when the players cannot
attack this Tower does not seem to be
able to attack me either though this
Tower is a puffer fish in this case
because the render is wrong
um Can these puffers attack no they
can't right oh what you can't get near
them that's
weird why can't I get any closer than
it thinks that there are
[Music]
well we're going to have to invest in a
little bit of uh some debug tools I'm
sure so we know now that this is
definitely the thing that is uh killing
us oh let's do um
do let's just make sure it's the actual
attack button that is killing us and not
like the skill only
okay so we are taking damage no matter
where we are you can see
this and it doesn't seem that we're able
to hurt
them which is
weird some of the other puffers are
taking damage
but none of these ones
are that might be a
clue Target is get player
OB PID and
right where do we set
attack right attack is
passed
here and you get the Target from here
then you get it
PID
um oh and if it's going to be zero then
you're going to get hit and do I
have there's a piece of code that I
might have forgotten to put back in
compute
observations or I might have been doing
incorrectly
so I would have thought that this would
be enough
I would have thought that this would be
enough
to ensure that you have nonzero pids
be well I think we have another clue
though right because
there's another clue
here and the second clue is
that all of the red puffers are taking
damage none of the blue puffers are
taking
we do have the teams thing implemented
though the teams thing looks
reasonable and when you do the compute
observations when you compute
observations
gaining massive respect for indie game
devs as I watch
this
well to be
fair most of the bugs that are in
here um they're in here because this
thing needs to run about a thousand
times faster no much more than a
thousand times faster than your typical
indie
game so like this whole PID thing this
is a b essentially a bunch of pointer
Shenanigans for the sake of performance
that I would not need to do
otherwise but yeah I would say games are
generally really harder to develop than
like big software is
let me just make sure I'm getting Target
pit
zero yeah we're going to have to
definitely speed up this Dev as well
because this is not this is not adequate
progress like there cannot be hours of
debugging
okay so Target pit
is always 0 through four sometimes five
pretty much always zero through
four okay so how is it targeting 0
through four right it should not be able
to see me
somewhere it's especially weird that
specifically it is always zero through
through like
five or Z through four
Dy player y plus d y player X Plus DX
right target PID it's on the PID map
um if
um was it
PID do I have access to pids
hid
hid is not equal to do I have access to
self.
pids yeah I
do if it's not equal
toga1 then we're going to draw a
rectangle and it's going to
map RB client has no attribute
pits course
lovely we've got to pass
issue I thought I was very careful about
this as
well okay well we need some viz
tools to be able to diagnose this type
of
stuff at least we found
it this is 100% the issue
so when you call move
to you have the
destination which is not this at all I
don't know why the heck I have it as
this this is a in int player doy so
thanks can AI auto complete sometimes
reasonable actually this is pretty nice
because this gives us a way to
um yeah so now the pids are solid now we
can can we attack
stuff oh well we're attacked this thing
right it's losing Health we're losing
more Health but it's losing
Health
right yeah and then we die okay it makes
sense and we can kill the
I think we commented Tower attacks right
so let's just uh can use your
skills and oh the
towers are do not have commented
attacks let's go check on
that also
hold
on looks so great how many time you
making this game uh this is day three at
the
moment
and and this is how it was looking as of
yesterday
could run around there's like reasonable
velocity can attack stuff there are
couple skills pretty
welcome let me think all it's all online
as well by the way it's in um puffer lib
if you like my work and want to St the
repo it helps me out a whole bunch
puffer AI puffer
lib let me see here so
MOA what did I mess up
here grid is equal to age of type oh
well this would be
why
um if
um do
type into the
tower agent type is equal
to Tower LS
try
this does this now
render hopefully this renders Towers now
uh I forgot to
rebuild we should render the towers as
us a different asset of stars
okay so now the Stars render here we can
see the debug
tiles um we're not getting hit right
now okay I didn't mean to attack that
Tower
but why I'm not attacking the tower why
why are they getting why are they
getting
well yeah I could see how that would
happen actually
okay I mean that's in a reasonable
enough spot um let's see if we can
figure out if the towers are actually
doing
something
so Tower and range num
Towers get Tower through entities of idx
plus num
agents agent changes color to red when
it gets hit wait really
don't oh I see yeah the problem is that
some of the puffers are supposed to be
red okay my skills work uh I this AOE
thing works my heel works so these work
um if I now go yeah if I get in range of
this thing it dies like it slowly dies
what if I go from
above does this make a
difference yeah okay so I see what's
happening here it's just the order that
um it's just the order that these things
are presented in
as soon as I go below this it starts to
die and you'll notice it's not hitting
me at all so this is just a loop order
thing and also my abilties is just
delete these things instantly Okay cool
so they're not attacking me let's figure
out
why yeah I got to do more of those
overlays to like indicate stuff that
would be useful
so right
here you go through the
towers you get the Tower
position you get your discret
values you check the
PID check the
team okay
so print some
triggering okay so we
get hold
on we get Tower is checked
though
detected detected one team wait Tower is
one let's see if we can get it like this
if we can get them to detect him
so okay so it detected me a
bunch detected
zero team
zero I am team
zero but that should be team one
okay so maybe I just did the tower teams
team wait what it it's spawn Tower is
idx team right
yeah these should be the right
team unless I did it
backwards oh wait wait there is a hit
it's saying hit
see so we heal and what's this going to
say if I sit up here so it says
detected it detected me but didn't hit
me
now it's detecting me but it's not
hitting
me because it thinks we're on the same
team wait what did it just show one for
a
backwards no they
all why the heck are all the towers on
team
[Music]
zero wait yeah the towers are all on
team
I clearly have it right
team I clearly have it right here I should be spawning some Towers at
here I should be spawning some Towers at
tier team one right
right yeah I don't overwrite TM anywhere
here obviously
well wait you don't need to
do you don't need to do this check first
of
all
Target
player this Tower is no longer needed
here and then I also need uh I don't
need this check in
H this is probably where I should take a
break but I'd like to solve this before
I
do it seems like it should be very
simple
entity gets the entity directly
right get Tower gets the tower
index and it can
see but it thinks everybody's on team
zero
whereas the tower should be able to be
on Team
One detected zero team
grid well here let's
to let's open this
up and then after after this resets I
want to check want to check the
attributes I like to check the
attributes
here self was it self.
entities uh.
team okay so the tower team looks fine
here
fine yeah okay so the entity's team is
correct the tower should be able to see
that they are on the correct
team um so let's see why that that is
not the
case Towers
team
type the
tower print
Tower
team attacking target.
team
R
Hit is puffer lib only intended for game
environments
no it can be used for just about
anything
um we just added support for continuous
action spaces but generally it's
anything that can be bound uh with a gym
spaces spec which is basically any
simulator we use games for most of our
test cases because they're commonly used
among
researchers and because they can be made
computationally efficient enough to do
things with uh I do have some people
that are interested in adding robotics
types M soon so hopefully you'll see
some of that in the next few
weeks we will
see
what why do I not have any messages
popping up here
toga1 did not rebuild I guess it just
didn't build
me I heard you talking about a possible
Pokemon simulation test is that a
project you're working on yes that's a
very active
project so this is originally by uh
Peter whidden it's uh right here and
there is a Discord for this uh this is
one of the projects that I'm sponsoring
compute for as well as advising and I
also if you check
puffer if you check the puffer
repos popper is the host
of uh
the Poke gem package for this
environment we got lots of different
branches of stuff on this uh there
people on the Discord active with this
and it's bound to puffer lib and it's uh
like three times faster and puffer Li
than anywhere else or whatever two to
three times
faster very much still an active project
we're trying to solve all of Pokemon Red
with reinforcement learning
this bug is taking way longer than it
should to get rid of
very
weird for
okay so now this
one this works
attacking
team zero and then when you do self.
attack wait it's self. attack Tower team
one PID Target PID damage
right PID Target PID
damage so if
uh
player. type is equal to a tower
print a
tower
is
team what
there not sure I understand the bug
what's happening the towers aren't
attacking
back
um and it's very weird why so
how is this possible we're getting this
first print but we're not getting the
second
print what the heck
wait wait a Target
a tower is
attacking okay this is target. PID so I
assume this is
ne1 this has got to be negative one
right so something is screwy
toga1 wait no no no no I have it
backwards I have this stupid thing
backwards
yep I've got it stupid thing is
backwards this is tar this is tower. PID
and this is PID because the PID is right
there and uh target. PID
is this is tower.
PID what did I have I had target. PID
right
ah you get the entity with
wait oh it was because it thinks it was
attacking itself is why that's got to
that has to be it I
think this has got to be
it can not just
essentially everything seems to be on
the same team issue of towers not
attacking
back yeah yeah that's that's it um just
basically just obnoxious bugs because
these pids are essentially like these
are essentially Jank pointers um that
I'm using to avoid copying lots of data
around and it's really easy to confuse
them that's
all okay so it just hit me back right I
can just see it look it's hitting me and
now I can kill it I can heal
so I'm pressing whenever you see it take
a lot of damage it's cuz I press q and
whenever I heal it's cuz I press W so
look I'm going to take some damage I
guess I wasn't quick enough reflexes are
bad okay so I have some damage I press W
I heal that's a skill um I go into this
I'm going to press q i I take it out
quickly I heal I hold Q here and I
wasn't quick enough there now it works
solid we're going to commit this
hours okay this is uh public this is all
public by the way so you can feel free
to look at it I'm going to take like
five minutes I'm going to go use the
restroom going to go make a shake clear
my head and then when I come back um we
I think we're going to already just
start looking at the creep AI I'm not
going to say we're going to do the whole
creep AI today but we're going to at
least think about it the main thing is
going to be like I don't know how to
make the creep AI fast that's the thing
that's sketchy so we're going to have to
probably spend some time thinking about
it before we start implementing um but
we're going to do all that live so I
will be right
stuff oh there's a lot of chat stuff all
of a sudden uh hold on let me get this
puffer out of the way whoops that's not
what we wanted to do
puffer thanks for sharing love be part
of this further it's all open source
join the discords pitch in however you
like
um we're definitely looking for
contributors accuracy and performance
versus
speed and
accuracy yeah I think that the thing is
with puffer you're just going to get all
of them are puffer fish the champions in
this game I don't know I think it would
be funny uh we'll probably get some
better assets I mean I have the thing
animated you can see it puffing on the
screen right here where did I go I well
I went to make a shake for lunch I'm
back here
um this counts as
lunch I saw your dissertation video and
thought it was really cool how is this
different from what you did there um
this is about a thousand times higher
performance for one it's also a heck of
a lot
simpler um but there there's going to be
some follow-up stuff to my dissertation
that will be launching very soon um I
just have to finish it and I keep
getting bored and deciding to stream
cool Dev instead of finishing it so yeah
there experiment still running in the
background at least so I am making some
progress let me tweet something to
refresh the Twitter because it's
actually done amazing on YouTube so far
today but Twitter's been really really
low
um don't have anything super cool to
post about it so I'll just bump it I
good
nice okay so let's uh let's think about
this a little bit I want to start by
reading up a little bit on the DOTA and
the league creep
AI so let's just read the wiki Pages for
DOTA and league and see if we can get
any ideas
um yeah let's see if we can get any
ideas for that
so sweet got to go but good luck with
the creep AI check out the get later
when I have some time yep drop in uh the
Discord discord.gg puffer if you want to
chat and uh star the puffer libero to
feed the puffer helps me out a ton
thanks okay there are four types of Lane
creeps
melee range flag bearer and Siege I
forgot about the flag
bearer melee creeps spawn in large
numbers have more
Health range grps have lower Health deal
more damage attack from a
distance less damage against Heroes and
buildings FL groups are identical but
have higher magic resistance King
Aura grant their gold bounty to every
enemy with an arena an
area I totally forgot about these
uh Siege creeps spawn in every 10th wave
yep destroying either the enemy's
Barracks cause yeah yeah super
creeps I did not I do not remember these
at all
okay spawning so they spawn in waves
every 30 seconds I think you get three
or four waves at the same time if I
recall in these
games um
time spawn
location
stats I want the AI where's the AI on
these things
okay
Behavior Lane creeps have a set path
from which they do not nor deviate
normally the creeps walk down the lane
aggressively meaning they attack any
enemy which comes within their
acquisition range similar to how player
controlled units act when giving them an
attack ground
order if a lane creep gets aggroed and
the AG gring unit stays within the
creeps acquisition range it chases the
AGG gring unit until it is dead or until
it lost track of it or until another
enemy gets within range and draws the
aggro
off the aggro enemy enters the fog of
war the N walks up to the last slot that
it SP saw the enemy does not see the
enemy again it returns to the point at
which it left the lane belongs to AG
unit is outside of the L's acquisition
range and chases the enemy for up to 2.3
seconds
before returning to
lanee group which is no longer aggro
does not join other lanes even if they
are closer it returns to its own lane
even if it's the furthest
away so following a fixed path should
make this much easier it's going to be
obnoxious that we have to draw the
path but I think technically we're going
to be able to make it so
that if we do this correctly
until the creeps get aggroed they're not
actually using any expensive
AI
so all the way until they walk up into
Lane they don't have to do
anything we can also make the checks
for the enemy checks uh periodic they
don't have to happen every frame
H let's see how the aggro works in in
this and then we're going to read the
league page and then we're going to
start implementing so aggro Lan creeps
follow regular Auto Attack rules they
prioritize the closest the closest
enemies okay we need to do that we need
to do closest we haven't done that so if
a unit draws aggro and another unit is
closer closer unit gets
attacked not the unit which actually
aggroed them
interesting multiple heroes are about
equally close the one of which attacks
them gets prioritized well the one which
does not attack or attacks from the
opposing faction has second
priority the ones who attack its own
allies has least
priority so there's some sort of prios
system for the creeps it does not matter
whether the attack actually happens or
not it does not matter how far away the
target of the attack order is the attack
order alone is enough to Agro or
deagro as long as a creep are within
acquisition
range issuing an attack Comm command on
Allied Heroes diagr
them while issuing an attack command on
enemy Heroes aggr
them Behavior has a coold down of 3
seconds okay so clearly this is like a
very specific thing that's been tuned
over years for
DOTA multiple non-hero units are about
equally range have all the same priority
creeps ignore units which attack them
from further away despite them being a
bigger threat they prioritize closer
units Siege creeps always have lower
priority than Heroes and other units
regardless of what they do buildings
have a lower priority than Siege creeps
and WS have a lower priority
okay because they have to be able to
attack the towers
right if F Lane creep attacks one of
these those three unit types and another
creep with an attack range it switches
to
enemy only enemy units within the lane
okay so let's see how this varies for
the oh my
gosh let's take a look at the league one
page
Behavior oh my gosh they got even more
text on the league
one well minions have not acquired a
Target they strictly path linearly along
a lane until they find a valid enemy
unit on finding they will move towards
it and attack it within their range
minions respect unit Collision as well
as player generated
terrain first wave minions have modified
Behavior we don't care about
that nearby enemy minions will become
aggressive or aggro and enemy Champion
within their own variable acquisition
range under certain conditions when
activated by enemy Champion
actions all for help
priority choose their target using a
priority system enemy champions
attacking an Allied Champion enemy
minions attacking an Allied Champion
enemy minions attacking an Allied minion
enemy turrets attacking an Allied
Minion Okay so the priority thing is is
pretty important it looks like and
pretty
substantial so we're going to need there
to be able to be some sorts of flags for
like you know is
attacking there need to be some sort of
is attacking Flags or whatever
know like Target type or something like
that once a minion is chosen a
Target it only switches to a new Target
if that new target has a higher
priority the minion cannot acquire a new
Target that has the same priority as the
current
Target variable
ranges we evaluate their Target in
between a attack wind up every few
seconds so they don't have to reevaluate
that
often
Vision loses sight of the target the
minion switches to a new Target or keeps
advancing
um so I guess the first thing that we're
going to want to do is figure
out the fixed pathing
they probably use um some sort of actual
pathf finding
algorithm AAR or
something
um I guess I could technically do that
just very
I would think it would be easier to just
have way
points we'll just set way
points and it'll take
like the long and then the short to the
Waypoint I
guess
yeah we'll see how that
looks so
we set some way
points
we we set some way
points we Implement
that we
Implement uh some sort of local Target
acquisition
periodically if they see a
Target
they they move towards the
target uh in like a straight line
fashion so I think we'll I think in this
game we'll allow allow the minions to
get stuck on walls and
stuff um that's fine they just won't
know how to path over
walls because that will make it
faster so the pathfind will actually be
it's just like a simple Min Direction so
like you do the the long and then the
short or
whatever or the short and then the long
either
way yeah short and then long something
like that
um so when they see a
Target they path towards the
target until they're within their attack
range and then they
attack
return and then we can start like we can
see if we need prome mechanics and stuff
from there but I think just that would
already make it look pretty cool because
we'll
have no we'll have waves of
minions we'll allocate like some fixed
buffer of minions or
whatever
um there has has to be a pretty
substantial buffer of them
actually what is it is it like four
minions in
League or is it more is it five I think
it's three minions three melee to ranged
or
something
oops
[Music]
rest okay I have it I have some idea
let's start on it
this is actually going to be cool cuz as
soon as this is implemented it will be
recognizable as a Moa
and that's the full buffer for all of
them high level plan for the creep AI
high level plan for the creep AI you can
tell me if you see any problems with
this let me pull up the
map okay so the highle plan for the
creep
AI is to
okay so I'm going to set some I'm going
to they're going to start like here
right and then I'm going to set way
points so I'm going to set like a
waypoint here a waypoint here a waypoint
here a waypoint um here I'm going to set
like some number maybe it'll be like 10
Way
points and uh the AI is going to when
it's not aggroed to anything it's just
going to go uh shortest path to there
and it's going to use a really dumb
shortest path algorithm it's just going
to go like minimum it's just going to
like do the short and then the long so
it's not going to know how to path
around obstacles or anything but there
are no obstacles in the path so the only
thing it can get stuck on is uh players
it can only get stuck on players which
is
fine and uh then if a creep gets uh if
and you know maybe we'll do like we'll
have multiple of these
right like maybe we'll have uh some in
here or something for like if you lure
them we'll figure that out but
anyways um the creeps will go along this
way and uh they will pass to the nearest
Waypoint and as soon as they aggro as
soon as they see something nearby they
will use that exact same pathing
algorithm to go towards the Target and
attack
it yeah and there will be range creeps
there will be melee creeps they just
have different attack distances attack
distance is very easy to compute because
it's just
continuous
um to towers are no different from
players in terms of them being able to
run up and attack so we should actually
be able to get something fairly quick
for
this yeah that is the
yeah it's a good start and it's actually
not trivial to implement even just
this so you
know uh we're going to have to start by
fig how to add these and then we'll
figure out the way points
think we need spawn creep and kill creep
methods for now
yeah re
one KD
map need to have this
right it's just
where's the
um the player code is right here right
this because it's like it's like a very
specific thing to
um yeah this is so obnoxious because
there's so much hard coding here that
has to be
done I'm going to do it but it's there's
a lot of stuff here to think
Tower it was like
tier it's like
team team in
team
I think I need to make like to get these
some of these hardcoded variables out of
the way
position creep
spawns self.
creeps spawns it's going to be creep
spawns
then we
do Reep
spawns b.
[Music]
Zer
them I think I can actually randomly
spawn
them yeah let's let's do randomly
spawned cuz this is It's too many things
to hard code it's like 40 positions or
something so I think we'll just do it
that
um valid
pause where is
it
and false
while not
valid
pause
R see and now we don't need this one
don't need this
like this is like what
25 so
like this
is between
22 and 25
so Min
Y is going to
be
minus uh
20 well but it's it's this Top Lane so
we can actually go a little bit
larger this can
be you can use the tower positions as
way
points so I was thinking about
that but then I think they're they're
going to get stuck on the
towers well at the very least I need to
add
um wait can you're right I could can I
just spawn them like around the towers I
can just spawn them around the towers
can I
yeah that would be
smart wait no no no because you need one
set of chords
for you you do need one set of cords for
stuff
okay so I think that the chords are
going to be like right
here right they'll be like right
here which is
22 within some distance not move to move
to next yeah that's what I was going to
try to
do minus
30 128 minus
22 min X is going to be 128
okay
else wait Max X is just going to
be2
30 min
y equals
22 okay this looks good
do spawn y spawn
X we just try to spawn them in a
box and we can potentially reuse the
Tower spawn positions like you said
so the way that they're going to
pass we're going to do
what the
heck not what I asked
for so
we also don't have their velocity we'll
have to change
that but for now
we need to figure out how to make them
go to the
destination actually float
Dy
so
right I've literally written this
routine before hold
on let me go find it
me just go find some
code CU I know I've written this before
oh I do use
ABS oh I guess I guess ABS is
um is actually valid
then
so
ABS
DX if ABS DX is greater than Dy
wait but the thing is they don't have to
move in straight lines I can literally
just do straight line pathing because I
have continuous that's perfect so I can
literally just
do yeah okay I'm way overthinking this I
thought I had to do tile based pathing
this is actually one of the places where
um continuous helps us a ton so we can
just
do um it's literally just float DX float
Dy
on equals d x minus creep.
X
um the Y is T Yus creep.
I and then we have to clip this right
guess
line
now move
to self. move to Pi
kid and we do
um creep
do
plus
Dy X Plus DX is that literally it is
just straight line clipped pathing isn't
it isn't it that easy
D
float float
right and I think we can do this as a
position array
array Tower positions so we get for team
one and team
positions oh you're supposed to pass
these in aren't
position then I guess we'll not make it
AR struct
we'll just
maybe and we'll
do power
positions
uh wait it doesn't have to
be I
dumb this is fine it's
maybe I should make it simpler and keep
it to
okay I'm not going to change spawn
towers for now um we'll we will change
that later I want to make sure that I'm
actually doing something reasonable
first
because this doesn't even give you the
way points does
it
shoot and why is this so like why is
this so obnoxious to make them follow a
fixed path
I think I'm going to do 3D oops I'm
going to do damn it 3D I'm going to just
make this way
points CU then I'm not locked to the
tower
anyways and I'm going to do self
dot way points is going to be equal to
so hold
on so this is your tier zero you need to
start at the
tier three
Tower which is
25 no it didn't it didn't get this from
the suggestion and then you need to go
to your tier two which is 72
25 like this and then
it's
43 25 I
think and
then second one
[Music]
is
85 and then nope this is
obnoxious I'm probably going to make
like some tool to write these to a file
or something dumb just to make this
easier but for now
33 this
is where did it get 7285 from
8570 46 isn't
it and then it's
74 55
so now this one is
10433 uh
10666 10496 let me see does this make
sense
8546 and then 7455 yeah this is good so
these are the lanes for the
bottom and then this is now
let's see if this has any chance of
getting it
right so this should be 128 97 is here
then it should go minus 70
wait-
72 and then it should go
to minus
43 uh so this might have kind of gotten
it
actually that's
nice so
yeah this looks like it got it okay
so now we have the way points for each
Tower
um which need to
be you need to
append the other way don't
you so this needs to actually be
no not
this this needs to now
be uh
the Top Lane which
is 128 -
minus 97 128 -
25 128 - 97 okay or maybe it gets it
from here yes it does get it
from no it doesn't quite get it from
here
that's
74 85
99 it still didn't get it because it did
this weird freaking thing here
all right so it's
43 72 97
okay and then it
goes
99 H hard coding crap
six 96
66 three and we're going to hope that it
got the rest of them we're probably
going to have to like Mark
it needs to have Lane and Waypoint
doesn't
it in
Lane Waypoint
X waypoint's fine
reap into
Lane so Lane is
Lane was it no creep.
lane creep. lane is equal to Lane
now what garbage did this do just wrote
some
Waypoint
Waypoint the.
Lane dust y
self.
Waypoint Lane wayo one yeah this is what
we
wanted so now it can actually path to
the
code uh we need square root from
somewhere or can't we just do start to
the0
five like this
than think if it's less than
two now
wait so obnoxious how this
works no it it does
work
yeah you just have to say if they're
within the distance of it
okay than two group. wayo is equal plus
equal to one
and
uh if creep.
Waypoint greater
than I don't
know
something to
do no because then that you don't need
to do this because there's going to be
another another Waypoint is
fun okay so we
have something that looks basically like
creep
um and now what we do is we do uh the
aggro check
PID creep to get
entity looat
x. one don't need any of this
garbage now we need to do the targeting
is the thing is we need to do the
targeting so we do creep
Vision creep vision is
PID okay Target PID
is we get from the PID map right
um Target pit is negative 1
continue and then we
Target is going to be get
entity
team is not equal to creep
team return Target
PID so super basic pathing or uh
targeting rather
return1 if Target pit is not equal to
ne1 then we have to do
attack right
attack or I don't know five
damage and we
do dot Des no d
y it's going to be
okay so Jank code but the way that the
script is supposed to
work there's an aggro check it happens
once in a
while uh if
you find an agent that is nearby that is
not on your
team it will tell
you you attack it and then you set it to
your current Target so as long as you
can see it this is your Target and
you're going to path after it and you're
going to attempt uh you're going to
attack
it in fact we can do like this we can do
if l two distances less than two then
you attack it that's even
better uh you're going to path towards
that destination regardless
thing okay we're we're just going to do
this Jank for
now yeah otherwise you just pass towards
next way point
cool the creeps have spawning
you spawn it in a specific
Lane now what we need to do is we need
to make a spawn creep
wave
function void spawn
creep
and we need to know the current creep
idx as well
index so we're going to just have a a
variable that will tell us the creep
index creep
idx IND X to
Zero oops
spawn
creep creep index percent
PID
PID yeah and then we do creep
dot
PID Plus
agents self num
powers and then new move to creep.
PID okay so the
index this
is
reeps though like
so team and Lane
so team is zero Lane is
zero
um and you're going to do this
for let's say we do three creeps
each three three creeps per
wave def in
s.
creep x
okay self. creep
index it's spawned
in team zero Lane
lane team in range
two for
Lane
no obnoxious
just we don't need to the thing is we
don't need to know team here because if
we know the lane we
do and
team we do if
Lane and three team is zero team is one
boom we just need to know Lane so for
Lane
range
six then foron
Lane so for Lane and for
creep that
it because this gives you 18 creeps
right
yeah that's
we need to set the player IDs of all the
other creeps to negative one
the PID
right do that in
uh in here just
PID
one okay let's start uh let's start on
this I'm use a restroom real quick I
think we have the very basics of it down
um we have the very basic skeleton of
like what this needs to be down so we'll
see how it goes from
here
creep path should not have to
take
okay
well at least for compilation that was
quick
buffer mismatch expected float got long
that's
easy type is
numpy uh what do we do float
32 float 32 is
fine well it's rendering I doubt
anything cool is happening but
it is
rendering we didn't actually call this
spawn wave function yet so there's not
going to be anything here to
see we're also going to probably want to
switch off of the human mode for
rendering so let's do
that we need to record um tick I guess
the time
tick in
oops in
tick so we
do self
dot self. tick is
zero
step we'll
do self. tick at the
bottom plus equal
1 and we
do if self tick percent what do we do
it
so once per minute is,
12200 uh is that
right on creep wave something like this
um
I see stuff
spawned so it actually did spawn the
creep
waves we'll have to color these a little
differently
type
Reep if player.
team player. team cool
and then let us
uh let's see if this
colored
perfect so we do actually get all the
different colors
here and now all all we have to do is
get all we have to do is get the entire
AI routine to
reap which is going to be
obnoxious well we can do it the slow way
first and we can just
do was it enemy was it creep
AI
num
PID can we also while we're at it here
upscale this thing a little
bit do we have an upscaler
make we have the upscaler
here
yeah let's do upscale
upscale equals
4 res
something that was really
sweet
what this actually does
something and then they get stuck
here and these guys got stuck on this
Tower here
right so I was thinking I was just going
to randomly Jitter them a little
bit this is is so
cool wait we actually have
this does this actually kind of
work like is that a
thing I'm sure this is going to take ton
of tuning tons of tuning but
yeah okay the first thing I want to do
is yeah that's what I was literally
about to do is I want to Jitter them did
I just say that or did you come up with
that
independently I want to Jitter them a
little
bit oh I said it
I do you know I I'm kind of getting
annoyed with the amount of stuff I'm
doing because this is like actually
leaving me brain dead by the time I
actually uh I I start working on stuff
freaking this freaking run is like
kicking my ass this is to be this is
also followed by powerlifting so I'm
just like absolutely burning myself
here oh you think the 1,000 foot
elevation gain is bad huh
yeah
let's I've been hitting powerlifting PRS
as well like every week for the last
three
weeks uh I don't know I guess I I
figured Sunday uh summer was a great
time to write code and get in shape and
do absolutely nothing else um I did not
anticipate how tiring it would be here
where's my Sunday
Run okay yeah here's the Sunday Run is
16 miles with 2,000 ft of elevation
gain and actually that
was there's one even worse one which is
going to be what I have to do this
Sunday which is freaking where's the
stupid thing yeah here this 30k 2400
foot elevation gain
that's basically the gain of a ski run
yeah but the ski run isn't 19 miles
right it's
here I'll show you I don't think there's
a good
picture is this a
thing is there can you see
satellite okay
so yeah this is this is what it looks
like
where's the freaking thing yeah this is
literally what it looks like so this is
the start of it right there so you you
start with this hill and I that one I do
run I do run this one that's like a 100
some odd Foot Hill and then you get to
the intersection which at which point
I'm at like one well there's no point I
can put it I can put it up here
um so this section I can't run it's it's
too
steep
oops and then
freaking if you get to the the actual
crest of it where I start running here
again
um is this a garbage
picture oh no it just takes a second to
load
yeah so this is about where it
crests
and you can see
the elevation I mean it you start down
here so it's a 500 Foot
Hill freaking this dish
thing drive me nuts
today but if you're wondering why I can
barely string two sentences together
that is
why at least hopefully I can code some
very basic creep
AI that's easier than sentences isn't
it uh
let's do the Jitter Let's uh let's add
Jitter here um to
creep it's the pathing that you need to
add the Jitter to
what's the random float
thing in hold
let's just
do do two float TR
y 0.1
this uh and we're going to do 0.2 I
think 20% Jitter
it let's see if that does anything
different
they and they definitely don't seem to
fight and do other
unstuck well let's see if they uh why
they don't fight and do
stuff or get like
let's take this off let's do it every
frame for now even though it's
so let's get rid of this for now and do
like
this target
PID is the
target else you path
so they got
stuck I guess
it's weird that they got stuck
here I guess they the way points weren't
in a good spot
well but the thing is they're attached
to each other here so are they
fighting what's going
the L2
distance is less than two then they
attack
oh I bet the um I bet the attack
function doesn't take into account yeah
yeah so
creep. pit is negative
one I think you can just do Pit negative
one right
if creep
PID turn
I actually don't know if there's an
asset for this I should use the
different puffer right oh there the
puffers just went
flying there's a
puffer uh you can you can kill the uh
enemies let's
right oh they did they came and they
attacked you did you see that the
enemies they came and they immediately
attacked me they're way too
fast hello
welcome this is pretty cool do they
follow me no they these ones don't
follow me but these are the
creeps so we got to fix their way points
but uh oh look they I don't know why
they line up like this that's funny
[Music]
cool okay we got to fix some stuff with
them though so first of all
as funny as this is the Speedy puffer of
death is probably a little bit too fast
right so let's
reap I actually can't believe that this
like worked as quickly as it did
that's so
funny Dy is going to be uh self. agent
speed times this I think
right okay let's recompile
this
okay here are the
puffers you can see them now right they
like Jitter around a little
bit oh it unstuck itself so now the
Jitter works because it's uh a more
reasonable amount of
Jitter and I think that this way point
is just wrong from here or it's it's
trying to get to here
maybe no it's the way Point's got to be
wrong little silly that they don't get
unstuck from
here
oop they did just run into the uh this
enemy and die
cool so how do we get them
to what's going to be the easiest way to
get them to path bully correctly cuz you
know the way that it is now they're
going to get stuck on all sorts of stuff
right
there's the next
wave you can see that they got stuck on
some
stuff apparently the puffer fish have a
symbiotic relationship with a bacterium
that's responsible for producing their
poison creep acid
idea hey puffer fish are actually very
friendly they are very friendly and
dosel creatures
I just happen to have some assets around
for this project okay technically I do
have other assets I could use with like
proper characters and animations and
stuff
um they're not really well set up for
continuous movement though they're set
up for tall Bas stuff
let's figure out at least the
um the
issue with the targets
two three and then this next Waypoint
is probably the one on the opposite side
or something isn't
it yeah cuz it's mirrored that's why so
they're trying to go across the map
that's
why um
I think technically this Waypoint thing
will work I'm just going to have to like
paint waypoints at some point so let's
just make it work for
now um or actually look it's so this one
has to go to the
third this one is
correct this one one has to exchange its
last piece here so this piece goes up
here uh this piece goes oops this piece
goes
okay this piece
has to come
up
here and then this
piece has to come down
yes
okay and then this piece
let's see if that fixes it it's still
going to get stuck on the
oh
look they
Jitter or actually maybe they don't need
Jitter maybe they just need to move
randomly when they're
wait move
y
re Lo move
dust
Y is equal
speed two * two times agent speed
because it's plus one minus
one and
move
two okay let's see if that does it
whoops
Rand
X don't need this anymore so now it's a
no Jitter until it's stuck and then it
Jitters a lot
puppers this is moving random because I
think I did it wrong this should be if
it is empty not if it's not empty
you have to make sure that you're not
the thing that you're not blocking
yourself it's
weird because you can move partial
squares
see here they go
fight fight
fight killed
one uh why
here do they not Jitter out of
it why do they not Jitter out of it here
is what I want to know let's render it
with human
okay let's
see let's see if we can go find some
stuck
puffers here are the
puffers they're
stuck why you stuck
puffers why are the puffers stuck
they should be jittering
no they don't Jitter they're just
stuck is that a tower they're getting
stuck on yeah but they're supposed to
Jitter so I tried to make it here
so if the place they're trying to move
to stupid it's this it's not it's you
have to check that it's not empty
okay the
bugs
welcome it's going to be so cool when it
works like you're going to see like the
little you're basically going to see
like a little mooba game play itself out
because they're going the waves are just
going to go fight each other until
eventually like one of them takes a
tower and they'll kind of like push back
and forth like that for a while it'll be
real cool
maybe are there any
puffers or are they
stuck oh they're
I don't understand
this if where they're trying to go is a
full
eventually this is going to be cool I'm
just
it they got stuck on the edge
there and then they
fight oh they took a tower you saw
that they actually just hook a tower
well they shouldn't have been able to
take the tier two that
easily okay and then they get deleted by
the tier
three that's so
cool man that is like okay the pathing
is still crap but
like the fact that we have something
remotely resembling a mini MOBA in
600 lines of
scyon
right we've got something that actually
kind of resembles a mini MOBA in 600
lines of scyon in a way that is
formatted for reinforcement learning as
well and we'll be ultra Ultra fast as
soon as we bother to do any optimization
on it because like just the way that
it's
holy
okay uh so they got
merked and now these guys are going to
come try to
take n they're going to get wrecked by
the tier three though they will
eventually take a tier
three seems some get stuck in Corners
yeah it's because of the it's bad
pathing objectives I think
we could actually just give the players
the creep AI as well right and just have
them run down
mid or like assign a couple to each lane
or
whatever also hello I just uh I saw your
presentation and been a follower I do it
work for living but enjoy this field
immensely and absorb what I can yeah
glad to have you here hope you uh you
find some cool stuff I've just been
streaming my Dev lately and it's been a
fun
time stuff like this is just so
cool I mean stuff like this is just
awesome I mean like like look at it
we've
got a little bit more tweaking it's only
5:30 I can do this for another hour at
least like we're going to probably have
a way to um to get something that's
looks pretty cool by then
right
yeah let's do that it'd be fun
for new folks here uh all of this stuff
is open source
it's all in puffer lib if you want to go
ahead and give the puffer a Star Puffer
like stars got to feed the puffer it's
much
appreciated let's commit all this real
quick
could probably spawn them at their home
base
Um this can just
be
oops self.
respawn PD right like this and then this
thing will go
into the respawn down here
and this will
be spawn y spawn
X
and player. team entity let's do entity
entity. team is
zero
entity Health
right
oops valid
pause
uh and all this these other garbage
variables are needed as well aren't
they
team let's do like this then
oops we can actually maybe even start
training these tomorrow we'll
see that' be cool
right today's
Wednesday it'd be really sweet if we
were training agents tomorrow I'm just
saying okay
so here we have the the uh the
agents no where are
they why are these ones over
here these ones are down
there what would you be wanting to train
them on oh I just train them I'd give
them a reward for getting to the other
side and see if they learn to like fight
and do stuff along the
way right
thing I mean this is very very early on
in this project right this is literally
the third day I've been working on this
and I haven't done I think I did like
two 7h hour days it's not that much work
um
so it's going to be a little while more
before we get something really cool but
just to have some basic something or
other working
yeah I'm pretty happy with it um we're
going to see how fast I can make it run
and all of that but looking good
this is not needed
anymore not needed anymore and we can
do respawn pit
okay so now we have agents
here they can actually creep block
already which is kind of
funny it's funny how none of the uh
these ones die at
suspicious why are the white ones not
killing any of the red
ones like to know
that is it possible there's like some
weird directional bias
thing going on
Target looks
[Music]
fine okay so
um what do we have to fix from
here it's a good question
think we can do is it how many creeps
are there in League I think it's like
creeps are any of the white going
through or is it just
all let's let's see uh render mode
human let's play
it sometimes
cannons it's a lot of
creeps it's a lot of AI to have to
run so
whoops follow the
minions
oop
oh are they
fighting oh they're getting mowed that
they're getting mowed down holy
are these things
killable yeah they are killable with the
abilities they were taking damage from
stuff one red one took
here come the puffers run it down
mid full
send
Attack lead the puffers to
Victory
attack oh I
I'm in the fountain killing your
dudes
oop and they get uh they get mowed down
here before they even get to the uh the
tier three because they only have two
range report puffer feeding
hey feeding is completely allowed okay
you have to feed the puffer it's
required feed the puffer though I am
absolutely going to steal that joke for
Twitter
I'm actually going to steal that joke
right
now let me make a gift
I didn't get a good
clip they're so
fast why are the puffers so fast
it's okay I'm going to have to do it off
screen and then I'll just show it
because I can't drag the window and play
at the same time
yeah okay that's a good clip I'll show
it let's let it
save you actually have to play the
mobile well if in order to get a good
clip that's so
funny you actually have to be
good you have to be good at the puffer
feeding game
I should get rid of these blue squares
actually for a clip
right it would look way
better yeah I forgot about those okay
one more try
why is this all called
puffer uh well there's some some
personal reasons but the main thing is
that this is an infrastructure Library I
have nothing visual to show you for what
this Library does or like stuff about it
so you know what screw it here have a
puffer fish that's the reason and it's
very funny it's very memeable and you
can like feed the puffer lots of
different libraries and environment and
it gets bigger so it's fun that's about
it I know what you were
perfect the towers can be Coral yeah
they totally could
help my puffers are feeding and my RL
Noob team camps
awesome I'm actually surprised how well
this thing
works I did not expect it to actually be
kind of fun on day
so it's
5:46
um I don't want to quite go until 7
today I don't think
maybe I will we'll
see uh let me think what I want to do
though there's a lot we can do with from
here now that we have the Bas the basic
let's open the
dock also I'm curious if my carb sweep
has done anything
let's
see is one be not
working
n well here's our thing
So currently
implemented how much are you wanting to
sim simulate a typical MOBA game
session uh the goal for this is to be a
strip down MOA that will still be like
kind of fun to play not like oh I want
this to be a thing on Steam but like you
know it's kind of fun to play around
with um which is more than you can say
for most RL
environments um I want to be stupidly
fast to run bare minimum is a million
frames per second though I think I would
really rather have this be more like two
to five million frames per second if I
can manage that we'll see
um we're going to want to have this
thing
let me think what
else well we need to have at least the
basics of a mobo right so they're three
lanes they're five Heroes the heroes
have uh somewhat different
abilities right um hero there's probably
going to be some sort of experience so
Heroes can level up there may or may not
be items it might just be experience
we'll see
creeps maybe different types of creeps
maybe not we'll see what we do with
that
um what else is there to am
MOA it's mostly it to be
honest think just like strip really
strip down basic MOA um it's still going
to be interesting it has to have
interesting strategy to it like there
has to still be
like here it like it should be the case
that if I put like a 2,000 ELO DOTA team
up against an 8,000 uh ELO or MMR DOTA
team uh in this game like the 2K1 would
get merked because they're like there
should be some sort of cool strategy or
whatever when can I add my credit card
for new puffer
skins it's all open source you can
download the thing right
now yeah
the only monetization for any of this
work is going to be like if companies
start using my stuff and want support
contracts or stuff like that then yeah I
can do that but uh other than that this
is all just open source Dev make
reinforcement learning
awesome currently implemented um we've
got basic
map um
movement uh
attack uh basic
skills
um basic creep
AI we waves and
AI uh prior things that we could
Implement things we can
Implement uh
levels more stats
maybe uh hero specific stuff with more
skills some
better
UI what would a good duration to
complete each run
session with that
speed
um good question I actually don't know
how long I want the games to
be yeah no idea we'll
see could be a few minutes could be a
few tens of minutes you know any where
between like what is it like a DOTA
burst game or whatever what's like the
rapid rapid DOTA
lck games 20 to 23 minutes that's still
going to be pretty
long um for RL we'll
see oh we also need
neutral draw camps better
map better enemy
[Music]
AI maybe some scripted
AI
players I think adding some uh some
stats and like levels and stuff is
probably going to be the main thing
right like maybe we add
we probably don't need to add like skill
cool downs and
stuff but we probably at least need to
add
Mana yeah let's add
um let's add like mana and stuff that
sounds fun
we can do that real
quick dud this is just so cool to me
though
like the fact that we actually have this
working at all and it's actually like
kind of
oh man I missed all the fun
Parts let me show you how fun this is
I'll show you the overhead of it it's
really
cool there go the creep
the towers HP and stuff are they're not
balanced yet
but radiant has no
Towers uh they got
merked
yeah I don't know for some reason it
seems like uh dire has an
advantage they should be the same in
theory but they keep getting
merked pretty nice though and the whole
code is less than 600 lines of scon so
far pretty good pretty
good all right load to
Mana Load Max
where is
it the. Mana is Max
mana
and move
to or is it
uh I've got to start winning on the
Sleep game more so that I can actually
be fresh for this
Dev it's like disgusting I need like
over nine hours of sleep to function
these days it's
I'm definitely a bit tired here uh let
me think what are we going to
do did I not have it in a knit
somewhere I guess it's in reset
so skill attack
here now we
do this one takes
um this one
takes 30 Mana I don't know random
number
return player. Mana minus equal
30 and then this
one
takes clear down Mana this one takes 50
Mana
bars if we could just get like 30
billion likes on that tweak and uh like
a million stars on puffer lip that would
be great
then I wouldn't have to worry about any
of the other stuff be
great all right so this all we have to
do is add the overhead bars now and
we're set
right all we got to do is add the
overhead bars
where my Mana
bars oh they're
better I actually kind of like the idea
of making it just take the full
bar and have it that be just like Global
cool down
puff let's make it just take the full
bar
CU like you can't really you would have
to like uh put coold Downs anyways
otherwise you just hold the key
okay got to be really good at the puffer
mooba here
defend the
tower
boom boom it's
hard it's hard to defend the puffer
oh that's why it's so fast because I
have it on double
puffers we follow the minion
wave boom
and they absolutely Merk
you it's a nice that actually works very
very well
here is the next wave you follow the
wave
right
boom we fix the uh let's fix up a couple
small things
Target yeah I don't know why they damage
for for five that's ridiculous
let's give the towers like some
reasonable
I just want to get an idea of how oh
yeah
1800 tier
two
2500 this is armor as well
though and tier three is only 2500
ones inor it's quicker to it to destroy
actually
they actually have less and less
Health it's
500 okay
so now we've got to adjust the attack
damages
um what
what's like your health at level one
actually level one hero
health I'm just trying to get a sense of
scale
league is anywhere between 450 and 900
Health at level one
right I think that's what I remember
so it's better to make numbers
lower in
uh RL
but let's
do so this is going to be
500 500 Max
Mana one it doesn't need to
be creep health
is say
200 is that reasonable I don't
know 100 is
good
so the creep AI they're going to attack
with five now which
is 100 DPS I
then skill attack is going to going to
be uh 200
damage the skill
maybe no that's crazy I set the minion
one way too high didn't
I okay they do 40
DPS player can do
uh 100 DPS I think
all right see you
around thanks for dropping
by I'm heading out as well soon I'm just
going to try to make this like feel
um and 10 maybe like this let's see how
this feels
yeah so the tower does kill you which is
appropriate
can I go drop a nuke on the tower like
this
yep and then you can go heal right this
and you can go kill the tower the rest
of the
way and the tier two is much stronger
whoops
have you made some good
progress uh see for
yourself we've got some creep
AI
Boop we've got creep
you kind of have a little mini MOBA now
you've got
better we'll have to do a little bit on
the the human player control side
but and if you wait here you'll see a
whole wave of minions spawn these guys
are dumb they've not been reinforcement
learned yet
okay here's our wave so we are going to
go with the wave and we're going to
still get wrecked by the tier 2 Tower
because I haven't implemented leveling
yet but we're going to kill this whole
wave with our
skill and we did some damage to the
tower there you go
think we could start just implementing
some of the basic hero skills or at
least designing them
right why don't we design some of the uh
the hero skills
um are you self t or did you do
college I have a uh a Bachelor's of
science from Stanford and a PhD from MI
ago let's design some of these skills
for uh let's design some of these skills
so I the problem is I haven't played
enough
DOTA I've played a little bit of
League All right so it's like right
there's like we need like
support um usually has like some
engage
or heal or what ever
skill there's uh
a what is it the bottom
is is like a carry
roll which is like high DPS
squishy
is uh mid which which is
like usually
also High DPS
squishy but like a bit less DPS and some
more sustain or some more like 1 V one
ability
um and then there is like
top which is the tank usually tank roll
and there's Jungle which is like some
sort of like well it depends if it's a
scaling
character
um but usually has like some clear
ability not always actually some of them
have really
clear usually has like some way to
kill
uh jungle position is really varied
isn't it
jungle's kind of
varied you've got like the assassin
types you got brawler
types really
varied that doesn't actually have like a
a well- defined identity does
it I mean we could make it well
defined right so let's just say this
let's say the jungle roll
has um has like really good clear
right clear
and has clear and assassinate or
something right let me see tank roll has
ah this is what I get for having been
freaking bronze in league and having
barely played
it I'm learning how to code right now is
cs50 from Harvard good uh I don't know
any of Harvard's
curriculum
uh Stanford's courses were all right um
I think a lot of them are online as
well um but yeah for you can probably do
just about any intro course to be
starting
um I know pick something that pick
something that you enjoy pick something
where the lecture the lecture is not
completely
boring midtop and jungle can all be
interchangeable depending on the hero
and meta yeah but the thing is I don't
want it to all be interchangeable right
like I just want to design five Heroes
and have it be a mirror match um like
we're not going to do a drafting stage
with reinforcement learning um that
would be a
pain so I just want to like make some
cookie cutter rolls and just see like if
they can like do something with those
rolls and I'm going to exaggerate it a
whole
bunch oh no welcome so what I'm doing
here uh this is a MOBA for reinforcement
learning I'll show you what it looks
like right
now this is day three of the project so
I really just started it but um I mean
it is playable and it is kind of fun
already let me go grab it so here are
our
minions we've got some basic skills that
we can
use nuke
them and now we're going to fight the
tier one Tower and we're going to get
merked so let's run away we also have a
heal
skill so I heal cost my full full Mana
bar and now uh when the wave comes we
can go and attack it again I guess have
an implemented leveling have an
implemented
classes uh this is basically it but this
is going to run super fast for
reinforcement learning the target for
this is going to be bare bare minimum of
of a million frames per second and I
think it's going to be much faster than
a million frames per second not rendered
frames but uh local state frames either
way you're going to be able to train
this thing very very
fast goal is for it to be like you know
mildly fun maybe has like some
interesting strategy to it so it's not
just dead simple okay here are the the
puffers boom We nuke them and now we
attack
attack almost killed
it okay that's the uh that's the game
anyways
we're designing some rolls here uh for
the end of the day
so top just has a ton of
sustain
and and some way to aggro as
well usually some way to aggro I guess
some sort of like thing with that jungle
has clear and
is let's just do like mid
tanky mid
damage it's like a little bit of both
the good 1 V one
character um
we'll have to think about what we do for
that yeah I know that there's the Magic
versus Fizz split but I wasn't wanting
to implement that so I was trying to
figure out like what is the identity of
these characters right like what is it
that makes them suited to the particular
Lane
um I got the carry right it's pretty
much always a high DPS
squishy right
be I think what we're going to do is
we're going to give the support an AOE
heal and we're going to give it um we
need to give it one other thing don't we
maybe we give it like a push back or
something to keep the car to keep the uh
the carry
safe stun is harder to implement than
push back but yeah basically same
um Carrie
gets it's a high DPS
squishy
so the carry is usually just attack
damage right and then has maybe some
like minor extra
skills is the game code going to be open
source my friend the code is open source
as I'm developing it I pushed 10 minutes
ago it's in this any config Branch for
now but it'll get merged up go ahead and
give the puff for Star to feed the uh
feed the project and
enjoy everything goes into puffer
lib it's all open
um so this needs to have like high
scaling
yeah of course I mean I'm streaming it
for this it's it's fun right uh so this
is going to have like
scaling uh ADC right it's a scaling
attack damage carry so it's attack
damage
um and maybe has
like they don't usually have crazy nukes
is the
thing
right mid is the one that usually has a
crazy nuke or
if a if the carry has a Mobility SK yeah
I guess they have defensive stuff
often Mobility is easy to implement as
well I was just trying to figure out who
to give it to
right like I was wondering I was
probably going to give like the um so
like here I was going to give the jungle
like an AOE damage like an AOE
clear uh like AOE uh clear like
Minions only and then like a like TP
plus
burst uh burst damage something like
that another thing we can play with is
attack range so like you uh sometimes
the carry has like long attack range
I'm back but I saw you were looking at
HP scaling and rolls yeah I was looking
at um this HP scaling and now I'm trying
to figure out just I'm just uh I'm going
to finish this up in the next maybe 15
minutes or
so for the day I just want to come up
with the skills and then tomorrow we'll
Implement all the skills and we'll have
like five distinct characters we might
add some animations even we'll make it
really fun
so the support gets an AOE heal maybe
push back carry gets we figured out what
the carry stat-wise
is I mean I could also just G like go
grab a bunch of characters and steal
their skills
right mid mid tanky actually usually has
like some sort of nuke um not always
mid-
tanky usually magic like you said which
is based around the Spells more than
anything so it has like average attack
damage and then like some good
maybe it has like a mid-range nuke
spell and then maybe it has like
a like an
AOE I'm thinking of like Lena
spells make them scale much better with
the solo XP they get from being mid
yeah but then the carry needs the carry
scills even better but the carry is just
way harder to farm up which is why a car
needs a support right
yeah so the top can have like a self
heal for sustain support gives naoe
heal and then aggro will be
like maybe a pull
right what's the twitch channel for
this JS
oops Yeah there you
go you don't watch on
either it's always live on on everywhere
twitch and I post all the updates on
X Twitter
damage mid has like
medium
HP mid-range nuke spell AOE damage
top and support usually have silences
we're not doing silences we're not doing
anything that's going to be like that's
going to add hundreds of we're not doing
anything that's going to add like a 100
lines of code for one skill let's put it
that
way if there's like a good mechanic that
would take 50 lines then sure but we're
keeping it relatively simple because
basically uh everything that goes wrong
I have to debug not only for the game
but I also have to debug when like RL
agents learn something weird and I have
to figure out what the bug is based on
the weird thing that the RL agents
learned how to do so like everything
that can be exploited will be exploited
by RL agents that can't complain in
forums okay supp Port has an AO heal in
a push
back medium
HP um Carry is is usually it's going to
be low HP it's usually low armor or
something but we're going to translate
that as low HP I don't
think does Armor have a use case for
this does is like armor really
important I don't think
yeah it gets interpreted as effective HP
by the player so we've got medium HP low
HP this is
high plus scaling
ad it's actually not usually it's
usually like just scaling ad not high ad
from the start
[Music]
necessarily long
range
range do medium
range long range it needs two spells as
well we'll figure that
out yeah I was going to do just
everything is raw HP that's what I was
going to do I figured that would be
easier this is for context here this is
not intended to be like a even a one
month project this is supposed to be
like a two weeks and done
project so
yeah there's a lot of stuff to fix in
reinforcement learning can't be stuck on
anything for too
long I will spend you know a little
longer than that if we're solving uh
solving other stuff in reinforcement
learning in the process but generally
like just for building an environment
getting some agents trained on it and
like releasing a cool Benchmark like two
weeks we'll have to come up with spells
for this medium HP
ad medium
range usually has like some medium range
nuke
spell and maybe some like long range AOE
or something something like
this so top has high HP
uh high ad
peel and it's going to have a pull that
does some
damage jungle is going to have a really
high damage AOE clear it's going to have
medium
HP um medium
ad a we clear that only works on minions
and also has a Teleport that does like
really
high uh like assassinate damage
melee so I guess this would be high ad
then if it's melee right you have uh a
like you're going to have high ad since
it's
melee so the top and the jungle both
have uh high ad it's just that the top
is way tankier and doesn't have the
burst damage okay this is this is
looking
good and
then mid is fine carry is fine support
is fine okay uh we're missing right now
the only thing that we are missing is
the carry spells I'm kind of at a loss
here because
Carry I've played I've only played I
haven't played carry and DOTA I've only
played
um like I've played like Misfortune in
league and
Caitlyn support get long range and carry
be low
range yeah there are low range carries
guess attack damage steroid
passives on hit
effects supports would do the trading
but pull back as carries get stronger
[Music]
making me want to play some league and I
know I I'm not like that game is not fun
I know
it game is tilting as hell
I need some if I'm going to do low D
like I would need a character to model
it off of like what is
a what's like a like a melee or low
damage
carry not doing attack
speed I was going to do everything just
in terms of like DPS the attacks get
applied every frame
I guess I technically could do attack
speed wouldn't be that
hard attack speed might actually be
worth implementing come to think of
it though I don't want to I don't want
to base it off of that if I decide to do
attack speed like the thing should work
with or without attack speed cuz like
high attack speed is the same as just
like high DPS
cares I'm like not remembering any of
these oh I guess like there are there
totally are characters right there's
them Yasuo I
guess is
melee but then has longer range
abilities that are more
complicated gyrocopter okay
yeah what are his
spells delayed secondary explosions
abilities
thereby so it has this channel thingy
yeah I've seen a gyrocopter like a total
of
once
um I want to look up
cm it's like a classic
right so this is a
slow a weaken okay that's hard to
implement okay so this is a route
more than a route
ultimate yeah this channel slow in
damage
assassin I've got like a few skills in
my head that are like okay that's like a
high impact thingy
um the problem is implementing like
roots and stuff is
obnoxious the thing like whenever you do
like something that has a duration then
you have to implement like a timer to
tick down on that duration for
everything that it affects which like so
I'd have to add like
um
well to be fair that's actually not that
hard I'm just being
stupid yeah but it's actually really
easy all I have to do is I just do um I
have to add one attribute to the struct
that's just like rooted and then the
rooted will just have like the number of
ticks remaining right and then every
frame you just decrease that counter by
one and you can't move if it's greater
than zero that's that easy for a route
same thing for a
stun okay so actually roots and stuns I
could
do slow wouldn't be that
bad root stun
slow Buffs these not that
bad why not map the expiration time
stamp into a dick then into decks into
it at each time step oh my
friend we don't have dictionaries where
we're
going you think this is python you think
I'm writing python
dictionaries okay I'm willing to do I'm
willing to do
rooted and by the way when I say I'm
willing to do I there needs to be a
reason to do it like there has to be
something cool that you can do like I
want let me think let's put it this way
I want you to be able to explain this
entire game to anybody who has played
Dota or League in five minutes right or
less five minutes or less you should be
able to explain this whole game to
anybody who has played like Dota or
League let's say anybody who's like
played enough games to actually rank
right at most five minutes and I want it
to be as cool as
possible given that constraint like I
want it to be as cool as possible and
like oh okay maybe there's some
interesting strategies here within those
constraints and I will crowdsource a
little bit of this development to you
guys CU I think that that would be
fun so stun easy to implement rout easy
to implement uh slow I can Implement
that um Aura I can yes I can
Implement if I have to do passives I can
Implement
like a damage or a Mana buff or
something like that aura I can do that
um some auras are hard like I don't want
to have to implement like
a
a some oras are hard I'll leave it at
that
um I can Implement teleports I can
Implement push I can Implement
I can Implement quite a lot of stuff
just not everything we're not doing
summons we're not doing like fancy
one-offs we're not freaking doing
controlling neutral creeps to use their
abilities
um I could make the neutral creeps
controllable technically with RL but we
are not going to be able to make the RL
agent take control of the neutral creeps
as the player character that's
incredibly hard
I did think about making the creeps as
well part of the uh the AI but uh you
know the fundamental game is part of it
is that the AI is
dumb I can do life steal
the way that I would like to think about
this is like I don't
know maybe you just think of like five
will there be items gold and experience
there will be experience in
leveling not decided yet whether there
will be items in
Gold I personally think I'm going to
incredibly regret it if I add an item
system because making characters buy
items is incredibly painful um
yeah I was just going to make it be a
nice chunk of experience for like
beating like for taking down a tower or
whatever even open ai5 scripted the item
builds I'm pretty sure
so one way to think about this would be
to pick like you know five iconic
characters
and then try to go as close to them as
we could right like Lena's a really cool
mid
right I don't know like cm is a cool
support or something like
that what's like the really obnoxious
engage tank is it t cash or
something cash the DOTA is this
league is this league
taunts might even be heroes I don't know
it's not Heroes of new worth I'm just
remembering the name wrong what's the
big frog character that like jumps into
the middle and like I don't know Roots
everybody or whatever else Tom kench
yeah that's what I'm thinking Tom
right has this really good engage or is
it this that I'm thinking of no it's
this engage right here I'm thinking of I
thought there was a DOTA one though is
there not a frog and
DOTA is there not like this frog that
like has like a really good engage in
Dota or am I thinking of this guy
don't think there is not a single fond
memory of this
guy
tier DOTA maintainer name is called ice
frog
yeah I I remember seeing like
some the engaged supports that have like
the really powerful stuns or roots or
whatever are cool or not supports
whatever this guy is I don't know I
don't play enough look I've played I
don't know 6,000 hours of MMOs probably
at least I've played comparably very
little
mobas I'm giving it like five more
minutes tonight guys um let's come up
with a couple things because as soon as
I get on tomorrow I'm G to start
implementing so I want to get like what
this is going to be so the
support tide Hunter ravage it's got to
be
that yep it's this
thing does he have like a Teleport as
well as or just that yeah I remember
like the tentacle things being like the
really obnoxious done
well blink dagger okay yeah blink ravage
yeah that's what it
was hooks very iconic like Pudge uh yeah
we can do it can't be a skill shot we're
not doing skill shots but I can do a
hook I can do a pull I can do a targeted
pull uh or I can do like an AOE pull
that's what I can implement
okay I'm going to just give you guys
your your toolkit okay this is what you
can have you can have
targeted or
AOE push pull you guys can have a stun
rout
slow um you guys can have like damage
over time aura
heal over time
Ora um or something like that is a
passive uh freck mana mana boost Ora if
you want I don't really think they're
needed uh you can
have
um uh single Target or AOE
spells centered on a Target
Enemy No skill shots
um you can have teleport to Target only
to a specific
Target uh you can have self SL AOE
heal I think that's
everything build something with
copying iconic he uh Heroes yeah so okay
if we're going to copy iconic Heroes
let's do it a little bit better then
right so we can do three
abilities so yeah let's let's do like
this then so model for support is going
to be
Lena oh no that's not support that's mid
I forgot that I played Lena as support
cuz I'm stupid um let's start with this
then model is going to be
Lena uh medium
HP
medium
a has an attack scaling buff which is a
little awkward to implement that's hard
but has
a medium range
nuke longish range
longish
range uh
stun AOE
stun
right
then we've got
carry uh I'm going to wait on you guys
for the carry cuz all I know is like I
know Caitlyn and like Misfortune and
stuff in um League I don't really know
any in
Dota uh
support
like a Hook support
maybe with a pull that doesn't combo
very well with a range
carry I'm going to work my hardest to
make a to make Juggernaut a thing in
puffer
Liv I can technically share this doc if
you guys
want I don't know if you guys deleted on
me you delete it on me I don't really
right Juggernaut is top right with the
spin spin to
win that's a hard ability
oh Jugger not to care what who the hell
am I thinking
of there's like a juggernaut type
character in who has like a spin to win
no it's not Garen is it not just
oh Juggernaut is the carry with this
spin
okay I think I got Juggernaut and Garen
crossed in my head
though channeled ability is really hard
to
do technically you don't have to eat the
whole Mana
I could well
wait I know how to make channeled
abilities I don't know how to make them
with a cool down but I do know how to
make channeled abilities we can do
channeled
abilities we can absolutely do channeled
there's not really going to be much
range on the team is the shame the one
annoying
thing okay so if we're going to do the
carry as Juggernaut Juggernaut has
doesn't he have decent
HP decent HP like medium HP I don't know
you're going to have to correct stuff
are you going to do magic immunity that
comes with it
nope that's
hard no turn speed melee carries can be
a thing there's no turn
speed fast attack
speed which is high
DPS so high ad I guess we'll can do that
uh move speed we can
do
and he's got like a
channeled
AOE damage over time I
guess what else he got
what else we
got yeah yeah he can move with it that's
fine I can Implement that I know how to
implement that I don't know how to do
the animations but I know how to
implement
it oh this freaking
Lantern is this the is this the thing
that you place that he can recall to
what is
heal uh I can't make a controllable heal
but I can do a self AOE heal hole that's
kind of weird on a carry though
right if we're keeping stuff simple like
wouldn't we put the um the heal on a
support
uh yeah I'm not going to get one to one
examples we're just looking like look
this is the goal I'm going to repeat
this one more time um
and the goal here is not to make like a
good MOA right the goal here is to make
something that is mildly entertaining to
play that you can explain everything in
to somebody who has played League or
DOTA in five minutes uh and that we'll
have like interesting enough strategies
that we can see maybe RL will do some
cool stuff and not so crazy complicated
that we're going to be balancing it
forever as like RL exploits
everything it's going to be a mirror
match 5v5
and to be honest I would actually prefer
it if the whole code for this were
closer to like a thousand than 1500
lines so we've got the basis of the game
like 400 lines to implement some
abilities some minor mechanics and like
leveling right not bad
hi Juggernaut as a carry feels way more
like um well I guess this is a League
versus DOTA thing right
like Juggernaut feels like it would be a
um like a jungler in League wouldn't it
it's got an AOE that's good for
clear
right I guess Garren is top so it could
also be a
top yeah I Juggernaut feels like it
would be a top character in uh in League
wouldn't it
maybe I'm not
understanding it's like a top character
type do we want to
do how about we do Juggernaut as the top
then we do like that as the basis but we
use it as the
top so like hold
on I don't know why I put so
wait yeah let's do
channeled AOE damage over time he's got
a self heal which is what will interpret
his lanternes instead of an AOE heal
because that fits the top identity
better I think is uh
selfish and he's got
a omnis slash is like is omnis slash a
suppress as well what does omn slash do
Ranger is Dr Ranger kind of like an ash
or like a
uh uh like an ash or like a Caitlyn or
something like
that like an ash
okay you can't be hit but
randomly you hit one target within the
AOE that's kind of weird okay okay that
doesn't fit as well with the
tank as
do I don't know how I much I like the
idea of having there
be multiple well this is actually kind
of a good engage right so let's just do
there be a
um have like some sort of like
engage what about like an Engaged dot
right that's kind of what it's like it's
like a heavy engaged dot
right heavy engage Dot
that's kind of like an Omni
Slash minus that you can't yeah I mean
it's not
perfect that's a cool thing for a tank
to
do got a self heal got a channeled AOE
Dot and he's got a heavy engage
um and we did him as top
here okay I mean this is about as close
as I get to Juggernaut in uh in puffer
Leb right mid will do Lena's got uh a
nuke a long range AOE and an AOE stun
that's pretty
Set uh we need an
ADC which is like a b
bottom
bottom uh so model is going to be wait
we didn't put
model model
juggernut
Juggernaut model is going to
be since we have a melee we've got melee
top we've
got we've got melee melee jungle as well
so I'd kind of like to do a ranged
bottom
maybe but then we can't really make as
good use of the hook can
support oh a Hook support still totally
knocks you out of position though
right it still totally knocks you out of
position
I just don't know how polished the
mechanics will be that that'll matter
hooked are you happier to get hooked
into like a Caitlyn or into like a big
melee Bruiser
right we can do it
anyways we can do it anyways
is Caitlyn has trap so Caitlyn's not an
amazing
model Point targeted hook would be
busted because it's guaranteed okay okay
so we'll do it so model is kind of going
to be like an MF or a
Caitlyn
um low
forever Dr
Ranger to be out of
position
okay BR I'll add I'm because I'm not
going to be I'm going to take abilities
from all these because I I can't
Implement all of their abilities um so
like they're only a select number I can
actually Implement with these
constraints
so uh from MF I'm going to take the move
speed
buff I'm going to take like a move
speed uh
Channel MF has one of
those
um I'm going to take a
uh
targeted uh slow plus damage like a drow
r or an
ash that kind of a
character and
then the thing that a bottom though like
the thing that an ADC bring is they
usually bring like a really strong
ability to a team fight
right not always they just bring raw
damage yeah you're right yeah I'm wrong
there they usually have some other cool
tool though um
Farm maybe they have like a medium
damage targeted
AOE yeah they'll scale hard on auto
attack damage I was just giving them
three
abilities okay
jungle I kind of like um like a nocturn
or like some sort of like Assassin type
y or
something so I want to have so this is
like medium
HP IID
melee uh they're going to
have
a AOE clear that only hits minions right
TP
plus first and one other
thing Google Docs bis for product
management so the difference between
product management is that I'm not
writing this do for somebody else to
implement I'm implementing it
right this is not echoing right I have
this muted
yeah well I figured that this would be a
fun thing to like kind of design this
with the stream as well
uh and this is going to be my job to
implement this
tomorrow so
oops no it's gotten way better since
this
one this oh this is not this is
uh Smite instakill minion button that's
pretty much what I was thinking maybe
not instakill but uh yeah this is the
environment by the way I don't know if
you saw
it we've got the puffers who are on
their way to feed they fed I have a nuke
button and then this Tower is very
strong so I also have an insta heal that
I can use right now I'm full
HP I can keep damaging the tower a
little
bit but they're going to kill me real
quick
Tower
anyways
jungle what do we
add that's some big progress good stuff
yeah this is day three this is day three
of this
project um not even putting in really
good hours like pulling maybe 7h hour
days being pretty tired I don't know
definitely not bringing my like my A+
game
here maybe my a minus
game move speed boost for the jungle
yeah I G I gave one of those to the
carry already though right
blink it's got the TP plus burst damage
here
maybe I don't need to give the move
speed boost to the support I mean the
the
carry is there's something else we can
give a
how about instead of a move Speed
Channel we give it like a
push me plus Target
apart I can Implement that pretty easily
I
this yeah I was thinking of like
Caitlyn's net which like roots
we could also do Caitlyn's net thing
that Roots
that net
slows Target
I don't I don't play very much these uh
TP
burst Quinn has a push where she volts
off the
enemy okay I mean we're going to have to
F tune all this stuff I'm sure AO clear
we'll just give this one like a move
Speed
Channel for jungling that's a pretty
nice fit with jungle you have to move
all over the
map so jungle bot
top
mid we forgot support
right who's the model for support uh the
hook like Pudge like a Pudge or a
thresh like that Medium HP low
ad well it's medium ad actually because
it's melee
right has a hook so it's got a a hook is
just a pull a we heal
maybe and what else do we need we need
one more ability for this
these freaking ads are so
gross this playing yeah okay it's not
playing
ever meat
hook oh he's got a damage over
time that's kind of cool
right we already gave a damage over time
like a simple damage over time though to
the
top you want to give it a
stun we could give him a stun
slow that's probably decent we can give
one more stun on the
team uh just like let's just do like
single Target stun
implement plus some stats and stuff
mechanics I'm going to go through this
one more time and then I think I'm going
to sign off for the uh the evening here
though it's it's funny how the stream
picks up at this hour um really awesome
thanks for the uh the support with this
stuff it's it's a fun time just doing
your Dev here and uh
actually having people like chip in on
stuff and
such yeah but people I guess this is uh
Pacific time cuz it's 7:23 Pacific here
which is late
EST my hours are screwy like I honestly
I'm try to I'm going to try to be in bed
in an hour and a half uh because I get
up at 6:00 to
so okay support is kind of like a Pudge
thrash character it's got medium HP
medium ad it's
melee um we'll figure out move speeds if
we're going to do like variable move
speeds for different characters or not
we'll figure that out it's got a hook
which can pull there no skill shot skill
shot so it's just targeted an AOE heal
it's got a single Target
stun mid is something like Alina medium
HP medium ad it's got a medium range
very high damage damage
ability long range uh AOE as well as a
AOE stun medium
range we've got the top which is yes
everything I do is open source um all I
ask is that you give puffer a star on
the way in and uh this uh what I just
have been working on now is in uh the in
what is it in
config some Dev Branch but it's in here
it's in uh puffer lib
environments uh ocean and this is all
the stuff I've been working in on stream
you've got the crazy fast like massively
multi-agent basically slither.io
environment you've got the MOBA I've
been doing you've got all these grid
environments it's all in
here all free and open
source
um okay top
is basically a juggernaut type character
medium HP high
ad move speed maybe we do that uh has a
channeled AOE damage over time a self
heal so there are two heals on the team
one's an AOE and one's a self and has a
heavy engage damage over
time so two different damage over times
uh this this is a single Target one this
is an aooe
one engage is like a Teleport or move
speed or something like that we'll
say bottom is modeled off of all of like
the long range poke type characters low
HP scaling ad Long Range uh we're going
to do something like Caitlyn's net or
something where they have some some
movement to get back as well as to like
slow or stun or whatever the target they
have a targeted slow that does some
damage they've got a medium damage
targeted AOE that's mainly for harass
and for
Farm uh jungle I was thinking like uh
model is like
a
here model is like a nocturn or
something
assassin medium HP high ad melee has a
very nice AOE clear for uh jungling has
a teleport uh that does burst damage so
has like a blink assassinate kind of a
thing and a move speed channeling
ability to get around the map
faster and those are our five
characters that's what uh we are
currently looking at
go this is cool man I'm going head off
to grab dinner might tune in again
tomorrow well thank
you uh did you do undergrad at mi2 T2 no
I did my undergrad at Stanford
I think this is pretty much
set I think we will implement this
tomorrow
and we'll go from
there obviously I haven't implemented
neutrals yet neutral creeps I don't
think that'll be too hard
I have to implement
leveling I think if we clean up the code
you know 1,000 maybe 1,200 lines for the
whole project is
reasonable
yeah that's pretty good
okay it's getting late here 7:30 I'm
going to head off uh grab dinner I'll be
on you know 11 or noonish thereabouts
Pacific
tomorrow
um after finals next week I'm going to
try to make myself useful on something
hey awesome glad to have the uh the
contributions lots of Open Source Dev
around oh uh our carb sweep kept running
and it didn't find anything better than
this solution it looks like but it did
find some pretty nice ones that's
interesting it looks like there a bunch
of blocks of like equal policies which
is funny to
see okay
um so yeah 11 or 12 tomorrow we'll be
back in on this and uh if you haven't
already give the repo a star it's all I
ask helps me out a whole ton really
helps me to like get this stuff out
there um all my stuff is on Twitter
which is also jars
5341 it's all science it's not like a
bunch of other random stuff unless I'm
feeling Mimi but pretty much just
this and other than that thank you
everyone and I will see you tomorrow